if YouTube is going to cooperate with
situations all right I see green
I see stream health I am assuming
finally 30 minutes late and we are live
welcome to the iron Louis vodcast and
the Lord's a gaming dotnet episode
number 128 and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the roundtable on
the Lord's Day
I'm very about our special guests and
we've got Shawn Leighton departure the
state of Sony Playstation now price drop
and destiny to shadow keep launch to
discuss so we go get right into it I
want to introduce a lord who I had the
pleasure of reconnecting with through
good friend to the Rome Lord Nintendo
guru
aside from leaving a PlayStation centric
podcast this Lord is the essence of a
true gamer a beacon of positivity and
along with Lord who that ninja utilized
his platform to bring all gamers
together regardless of their console
preference introducing the Korean host
of the bad--but Games YouTube channel
and Playstation trophy rule podcast a
wait no longer because Saudi greatness
and the birthday boy has arrived
live from Jersey and making his debut
into the realm of the Lord's mom head
Lord Joe aka mr. bad [ __ ] how you doing
sir yeah that's a great statue I've ever
heard I need to bring you out everywhere
I go you know like like I'm entering
class you're just there like the Lord
fantastic I so it's my birthday this
weekend this is the icing on the
birthday cake
I've been excited to chaste for me to be
on here and what a better week then this
week man like it's we got some news to
talk about super happy birthday sir
thank you thank you
I'm 28 man it's over
yeah just a December I'll be 28 yeah
I'm can't wait I can't wait of course
this guest of the round table needs no
introduction and has been a supporter of
the ILP from the very beginning now is
this Lord the epitome of detailed
destiny analysis but will his smooth
calm demeanor he easily teaches all
newcomers to the game as the modern-day
Bob Ross of destiny introducing the
created host of the abates twitch and
YouTube channels fellow co-host with
yours truly - the best destiny podcast
in the game the last firm and our
favorite shadow throne soloist always
cook it's a hot body can't find laughs
from Texas the cheetah making his return
into the realm of the Lords my bro Lord
of artists how you doing sir
I'm doing good sir it has been a while
but it is an honor to be back thank you
guys for having me back on this show
yeah just spent some about 12 hours on
the raid yesterday peaked at vex
offensive so a lot of stuff to talk
about for vex and for destiny and also
for PlayStation so good a good place to
be on so thank you for the honor once
again marshmallows today Sony but no and
of course we have the Four Horsemen of
gaming those original laws of the room
here at the round table
hold on dizzy with the finalists of each
era Lord yeah you know that is that's my
man straight Oh
look let's go kick might be the last
super chair for me for a while I hope
I've inspired others to take up the
mantle and fight the fight for saw love
you brother man keep it up now you know
that my calls for the cold most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game khakhra Lord of reviews
and the half of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict I do sir I'm just not used
to using this laptop for this podcast so
why all the settings are all messed up
well what's going on you guys I'm
definitely awake actually because of our
depth ago difficulties I wanted to jump
in the shower and I lie awake looking
forward to getting you back in the realm
of course gonna talk some good talk
today a lot of stuff going and you guys
ever notice like cognos favorite theme
for the intros is infinity yeah did you
get to epitomise I get really mom
and of course we have a most technical
gaming Lord the solo game of list for
the single player selfish experience and
also the Sasha Adonis mr. Omar profile
Illuminati and lore patron of the iron
bank Mahmoud Lord sovereign how you
doing sir
so non everybody good morning who
everybody had their brunch yes I gave
you guys a lot and when to do at the at
the attic since he was helping you he
said I would take a little nap before
the snow actually a little fix we get
everything straightened out bra fine
okay so he says I'm low budget cuts does
have lab we'll figure it out yeah it was
going mansion nothing like oh I got to
play with a little bit of Link's
Awakening this week that's it no gears
yesterday happy my Yanks are doing that
thing though man
keep it moving keep it moving nine to go
nine to go for that you have you have a
lot of things to be to be excited for
with that team I think stop it a lot of
things to be excited for I have me all
jazzed up ready to go and these dudes
fumble the ball let them know what
killing me is that the New York pick not
all of them put the New York Post he's
trying to diminish that accomplishment
saying because of the juice balls
there's no way he's gonna get that many
you know the man his rookie season
without the hit 15 home runs was the
juice that's it man that's it no and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer whoo the lord of
combat sports king of the statues who
demands nothing less than their premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement hmm beloved Lord King
they've been waiting how you doing sir
oh boy I'm doing fantastic and as you
can see the gold leaf is in the Dominus
but last night I got a chance to watch
triple G versus davidenko
and I saw the virgin go get Rob pou oh
my god he gets smoked like a cigarette
last night I mean this guy was getting
beat from pillar to post I don't know
who all these judges but these judges
really need a licenses revoked this the
travesty and boxes and that shouldn't
happen but it happens and you understand
what they trying to do but he fights
anybody of any substance any of real
substance I mean and every chenko was
really decent you know but he fights the
champion he's gonna get this boot smoked
oh I picked up links awakening Wow oh no
I told you net that's this I told you
when he start the game up nurtures
that's all
y'all gonna do a snow chain I'm doing
links and I'm gonna put it into the
purchases yesterday with my Microsoft
dollars Thank You Microsoft thank you
discover for sending me net that um but
at this point in time I'm really pissed
off with game purchasing it's come to my
attention that Daisy will be released on
the 20th and game pass this further
exacerbates the fact that financially I
should not spend a dollar because I
don't know what's gonna happen next
like I don't know if I go out and I buy
this game and it comes out in game
passive Emma so let me get this straight
let me get this straight they don't pick
up shadow key man wait wait for it to be
on game packs oh no see no no no no no
see what understand is that game won't
make it to game pass whereas you know
anthem should have been a day one sida
access and they actually put it EA
access now after died that's so stupid
that's why I you know they CEO needs to
go the way of Sony CEOs oh no my you
know we go I'm saying listen you know
destiny has their way of and I'm gonna
get into those dudes later they you
gonna see why it is never going to game
past because us fools will definitely
buy the same stuff over and oh we have
the law of the cooperative experience
and gaming ninja himself this shinobi
law kognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP now telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear you
already know what it is destiny to
shadow keep all day all along the grind
has been real talked a little bit about
on the last word with a bot says man
it's been a lot of fun man just getting
back a little bit our episode is almost
longer than this one general average of
these and we were marking at your door
so we doing it up man will talk about
garden of salvation with addict in and
get singer and sinister and guy boxy
with everybody but up yeah it's been a
lot of fun with that
and um yam ever quit UFC was outstanding
last night shadow to the style bender
you know I'm saying swagging on him what
did he do something root oh joy what was
dead I got a comfort I got to converse
with adequate anime stuff I don't need a
me so I just know he did a dance and he
did some thing and it would look like it
was straight out of some anime and I was
before the flash game was a tremendous
fight he got he got all what you call
oddity he got Whittaker out of there
just tremendous counters angle defense
was never off balance like he's such a
shame to my jewelry and nuts he's now
getting closer to innocent 2.0 he still
could be hit about mm-hmm but that was
his moment and he shined he shot those
[ __ ] little shot set up it bones
afterwards you don't say all bit
shout-out to brat with the $2 C which
Sony losing leadership like stadia
losing packets oh oh
we'll get to the Sony topics we got that
but anyway that was that was great fight
shout out to the hooker um Dan who could
really pieced up um I like Quinta I
believe that was a great fight against I
was off actually I must have caught it
but I wasn't really paying attention I'm
back of course look strong bro
he looks yeah well-rounded every way you
want it from the jab to fighting to or
the leg kicks the complete arsenal but
like I can't do that you know he's that
he's that guy you got a pass you know
right maybe he's the gatekeeper so you
think he got MIT so that's what I got
solve we will be making some
announcement sir yes we will sir so
first of all um I'd like to announce
that we're gonna move our patreon
announcements to next week since we're
so late we don't want to keep our guests
too long so next week we'll give you
guys a sign you guys deserve
I don't think we have any guests next
week so we can just focus on on giving
you the love you deserve so it's on for
next week but we do want to announce
this week is that if you look at the IOP
twitter account you'll see that we have
two new gleam giveaways for the rest of
the year and needs the big ones these
are big ones guys so go out there check
out our giveaways the first one is for
pokemon sword and shield about is of
course the Attic is referred to kijima
seminal game guys check out both of
those gleam I always go out there tell
your friends about it go sign up
definitely and we will be giving those
out right before they want to clarify
some pokemon sword
or or shield yeah you're not getting the
combo offer big offer dude that's not
what the Lords offer also also please
remember all those it doesn't apply as
much to us which games to switch games
I'll region-free
but you will be getting an NTSC reason 1
codes for both of these games so either
pokemon sword or shield
or death stranding another thing now
PlayStation makes a little more
difficult so if you are from the country
you happen to win and you win that's
Trani code I will try to jump through
the hoops necessary to get you that code
if not then we'll figure something out
we might have to pull that trigger and
just do xbox game we got so we're out
there and signed up for that already set
the stage and before we go real quick
shout out to Brad yes sir got two savvy
but oh yeah so I just wanted to bring
this to attention the lords real quick
obviously we got the gleam giveaway
geosoft laid it down popular demand you
know I've said we've been getting this
request alas we wanted to bring it to
the realm lord King first little debut
jump off you know saying one of the
famous IOP saying its sayings go to
right now we got that so over the bushes
y'all yeah the bushes is live right now
I must look your feet must be in Bush
you must you all the way in the bushes
limp rappers laughing boss we said why
you Bochy know that so come out they hit
the store shout the Lord King we're
gonna have a lot of King isms a lot of
Lord phrases from the room this is the
first one a highly requested is a yes
yes listen guys just like you guys I got
a lot of my stuff too baby
so go out there look fly young and
flashy with it roam in the bushes
and you know sometimes you working your
boss's ball just look at them listen
check out the feet see the feet is if
you slaughter you sketch that I sent out
for that then looks exactly like the
initial sketch and Kamino kognito was
dead in the chat it was a so again told
me the bushes and of course another
highly requested features I don't want
man monkey Punch's in the building
because this is he asked you this all
the time man those ILP hats are finally
here so we had work with T straightening
or fighting this a little bit on the
logo
so either make some adjustment but yeah
man we got that snap we got that dad cat
you know I'm saying so go check that out
if you want them flavors man we got the
ILP jump off jumping off grabbers like I
did that
shirt I got you oh we got that you know
we got your videotape I got the tape you
had when they were giving out the hats
you took the trucker from Xbox a gray
one that was what we's in the hotel to
chinatown hotel don't you start I got it
he wanted in that real clean a lot of
receipts oh yes I could get IOP to
simplify I hope you sure is fashionably
designed with the hat is a matching as a
set that you should wear wherever you go
as you walk down the runway as you're
going to get on your flight everybody
will know you ripped the eye oh let's go
look at the hood out the brat with a few
hours of Chaddock have you been to cheat
lake
you know you know so go check that out
I'm gonna throw that up in the
description as well we got the shirt we
got the Hat again long over dude you got
your dad cap you got your trucker and
you got your snap so go get those real
quick so don't put those in the show all
right so we got the business of leave
out of the way and a half gun of dough
it's you hub wrap anywhere that have we
gotten all the announcement out the Lord
way and then we seen what the laws have
been planned I want to start actually
before we start with a little bit
well obviously Lord Eve artists has
already received a royal treatment
multiple times please check out IOP
there was 68 on his last appearance am
68 if you tell them the last time he was
on so then you could tell them in that
one what episode of go to there to
listen to like three Park has to find
out when you got this even before that
IOP 34 his pals like yeah
no no jealous like it has been a while
this was like what what number is this I
missed it
yeah I was gonna say it's been way too
long so unprepared unprepared I'm sorry
a destiny high yesterday so G Lord and
they're good to see you brother
but um yeah so we got that 30 and then I
want to start with bad bit his journey
is a content creator and of course what
led him to youtube and the trophy room
so damn it lets the offer to get in man
what was the first video game systems
you had what Gatchina gave it uh so
again 28 so I've been at a game for a
while now but not like the first system
for me you know what wasn't like you
think of a person in their 20s it's
usually like n64 or maybe even like the
6th generation like GameCube or
something I go all the way back to the
NES when I was like 2 or 3 I remember
watching my brother play like games like
The Rocketeer Back to the Future
oh my god we played Turtles and time are
you kidding me Power Rangers let's beat
them ups by the
powerage yes turtles in time so that's
where I start
kind of kind of playing it or just kind
of watching it but the first game I
truly like remember playing and beating
and just absolutely falling in love with
which is super mario world which is the
best 2d Mario game as of the start file
okay yeah best bubbles you can unlock
all the different color Yoshi's mindless
blue
yes lose the bus it's still like yeah
like Super Nintendo was great and I
remember my hit my grandparents would
get the other system like the then like
the Genesis you see the so like we'd go
over there and just that that's where
the other systems were that we're our
main system like Sonic 1 2 & 3 Sonic and
Knuckles the first DLC pack yes ever
let's don't you guys back in the day all
the youngsters out there DLC was just a
cartridge you plug into the into the
console they even another cup like
cartridge into then you have a tower out
of a baby let's go do them awesome
awesome I love the Sega Genesis it's
actually one of my favorite favorite
consoles of all time though I haven't
played many of their games I just have
so many really good feelings of it yeah
memories and um ya know so like moving
from the fourth generation on to the
fifth use here's where you guys go to
look at me a little crazy oh let's get
to it
PlayStation 1 can be real with you that
was the console my grandparents bought
they're like this is what's gonna get
him into our house and stay with us and
not chemical
ps1 to my house it was against the rules
because they know if we put we would
just keep it you don't show up you show
up but like they wouldn't buy any games
for the PlayStation 1 mm-hmm just the
demo discs it's like yeah Crash
Bandicoot like it please Spyro but just
the first levels over yeah how was you
was the one game oh my god not Splinter
Cell but it was in that vein I love it
so much it's coming - yes how many times
they played that demo and they're like
when I bought the police station classic
Yanks I played the first level of that
game I was it's like how did we do this
he was the police station classic we all
make mistakes with minutes against the
part of growth when we admit I was from
mistakes we move forward no ignore the
order yes like like play the ps1 I have
really great memories of it just last
week because I brought it over and I was
laughed out we probably put it on once
shut up - Lord malecon that's in the
chat right now he knows when I brought
it over you were excited and then we
quickly lost all excitement that game
was never seen from again
it was so bad belly pulling as a kid
that's all you got right so like me we
didn't pick King of Fighters because we
don't know hat is so we we know starter
you love it alright so basically okay I
got it I got it
no I got it okay it's awful it's
absolutely awful it's amazing that's how
but then moving past to one of my
favorite consoles of all time is the n64
that we had in the house I remember how
do we got it because it was a big
argument in a Toys R Us oh and like yeah
my mom would say just give him the damn
console because we're never gonna hear
the end of it all right well I'm gonna
buy him the console like old-school
Spaniard that's what my dad is is it so
like fix your broken English but really
upset he say I'm gonna buy all this
console mama Bible innoGames my mom's
like that's stupid no games
it's with my death but grudging and he
bought us the n64 with shadows of the
Empire okay Super Mario 64 okay you know
you know it's funny you know what the I
got two games when I got my n64 I got
Rogue Squadron and in Glover wow there's
actually was rumor a couple like a years
out that they were making wedding stuff
so yeah got the n64 and that ended up
being one of my favorite consoles of all
time I often say it saved my childhood
because I should say will keep the story
short it was a very traumatic experience
I had no childhood life so that game
like while real [ __ ] was happening in
the background
I'll explain super I'm sorry there's a
house baby was mash brothers
I was playing Mario 64 I was playing
shadow to the empire so I didn't know
any of these things were happening in
the background
more than 64 one of the the first game I
completely 100% not was talk about it
and let's talk about the debut of the
analog yeah people don't understand like
just King solving and adding the
touching and the sensitivity and and and
remember you can make Mario like tilt
and move on a circle and it just changed
the game like people don't have to
realize that we have to give Nintendo a
lot of innovation sometime to innovate a
little too much but they do pioneer a
lot of things that sometimes the rest of
the industry copies and I remember
vividly that game really changed again I
gotta give it up yeah it's what they do
with with the constraints that they have
yes really makes Nintendo one of the
most creative I wonder like innovation
is a word people often use I think it's
really the creative side of Nintendo
that that's what games are all about and
so when it comes to Mario 64 it's one of
the first games I 100% it's one of the
first games that we heard rumors of
Yoshi that being the thing you unlocked
and that was just that moment finally
happened for us we were just saying
mmm-hmm holy crap so what do we do now X
so yeah for that was your baby like
you're one yeah that was the thing that
really just like if the SNES didn't do
it it is the n64 that really solidifies
I love video games right out the most
mundane is I got rushed 2049 in
Starcraft 64 shout the boss move this
n64 controller look like a Batman logo
that is anyone able to play it in like
20 different fashions yeah all of them
uncomfortable but yeah yeah I mean
goldeneye 64 dude it's the jam it's so
pretty good so see ya at 64 mm what a
system awesome then we get it see as a
kid I wasn't
[Music]
because when she was to the axis we need
to the PlayStation 2 Xbox GameCube I
remember the launch of the Gamecube and
then nothing much else like I remember
there was a meteor shower I think there
was something really cool but other than
that I like the Gamecube was the Super
Smash machine gotcha um and Luigi's
Mansion machine do you that game is so
awesome
no come on and then I my brother worked
at cop USA and we got a pretty yeah rip
copy baby that's a good time start times
but my brother got the original Xbox for
like I don't even know at what price to
us and that is when I became a total
xboxone fanboy
that's right that's right he's doing it
you're doing it right now I'm about that
so here's the thing
ps2 great console I remember getting it
for my birthday though being
disappointed it wasn't a second Xbox but
I'm not one of those kids who are like
oh one Xbox
I was so happy I got to play Gran
Turismo I guess that's cool and like I
use my playstation 2 for like things
like Kingdom Hearts mm-hmm Ratchet and
Clank new shout-out to jak and daxter so
many great games times Woody's as well
but what I think of Xbox and what I
think of like oh man this is this is
what I want out of a video game it's
combat Evolved right the first Mila it
had to be halo it just absolutely yeah I
have a Lancer in my in my closet well
get to the 360 in a second I like it was
halo and I remember that was my first
nerd like rage moment was like my
brother my best friend teaming up on me
in halo 1 and I like I hear I hit my
chief cbs-tv I left a crack in it like
how about evolved was it game that man
if there was achievements I would have
100 or what what does he called it man a
thousand KD at 1 Cayne it that is yeah
like I played it on legendary like on
Halo 2 comes around not even I was one
of the launch window of the xbox live
experiment says we paved the way no I
got I got the little cheaper a headset
that came with the salt which was to
comes around my screaming my gamertag at
the time war like coffee why it was one
of the dumb like named random named
generators because I and healer too and
then just enough said at that point what
the greatest multiplayer games of all
time hands down it it's what made online
gaming what it is yeah facts it's the
fine in the success of Halo definitely I
wouldn't Kohli Green for pilot propel -
as far as multi gaming being successful
in let's not understate like you know
the og even a lock and a lock in a tank
uh do you guys state just you know quick
quick at it like Xbox be where it is
without Halo like I don't think it would
I agree to me because they came out with
an aggressive vision with broadband
Ethernet in the Box hard drive in the
box so from again from a games
perspective they didn't have you know
they weren't big in what they're the
system itself wasn't successful but it
laid the groundwork for what future
generations ended up eventually copying
which is yeah I think if it wasn't for
Halo and Call of Duty I think that's
what made mmm-hmm yeah that's what it is
today it's it's really Microsoft knew
going in that this was a long term
investment right like this is a ten year
plus thing until we're seeing green and
literal and so I yeah I have so much
it's a good come on I miss nothing from
the controller ordered the ones from
Japan from Japan shut up unless the Lee
- who's that was that that we went in
81st Pete oh that was my dude over there
are here I forget well yeah we all we
used to go on 180 first up then shut up
forgetting us our Japanese fix to get
those dirty controllers out of our hands
you want to hear the coolest story ever
and why my mother all your mothers in a
fistfight Oh
all right here is the launch of the Xbox
360 okay this is it Joe was on a waiting
list game stop stop decides to screw me
over and not honor the list oh I
Wow released for Christmas and my mom I
remember that Christmas she's like jello
I'm not fooling you she was saying this
for a week she said I didn't get you the
Xbox 360 game stops to do this over it
and like she I remember on Christmas she
was a sec gem I promise you I will make
this up to you if I see you next box
we're buying it all right whatever and
it was a week after like Christmas break
and I'm in gym class in shakes or
seventh grade mm-hmm I get a call to go
home
okay and now my brain thinks the worst
I'm like stuff that happened to Grandma
I don't know
boiler should have been really worried
about my grandpa right you know what the
past is the past
so I walk downstairs and he kept
changing him just like having a panic
attack I walk into the office I'm like
mom what happened grandma yeah to happen
degree much today shut up I'll tell you
upset and like so she kind of confirms
I'm like what happened grandma my mom
she stops me in the middle of hallway
saying oh you know the Xbox that you
wanted anyway yeah well I got you it
yeah so I'm taking out school I'm like
wait for Xbox it looks you my mom says
the greatest thing of all time she's a
so what you want to go back to school yo
solo that's that's a fair answer right
there yes that's so
my mom has fueled my gaming love since
since I can remember I remember getting
call of duty to oblivion which oblivion
I did not understand nor get and yeah
like Call of Duty she was he's I broke
my 360 plane of oblivion that more women
I always wanted to instead of playing
the game efficiently always
want to use glitches that were not able
to be handled by those consoles no the
motor was like we missed a super chapter
brat with to our super chat xbox live
beta testers revolt NFL fever do
remember to remove any build-up continue
little bit yeah like my mom they're like
I'm playing call of duty to say okay I'm
gonna get your meatball sandwich where
you like your friend oh my god I
remember that moment like chillin being
the ultimate kid gamer at the time I'm
outta class at this moment grandma I
tell you when we get to the car my mom
pretty cool because they so I have
hernia right now but my first hernia
surgery I hmm
sucks so bad I needed to know under moon
but like I remember I remember after the
surgery it was during my keyboard days
right and my mom was just like like you
know I I thought you know like save up
for money a little bit after my surgery
I'll finally be able to play with my
friends I wake up and my mom's like hey
dude I got you got you a little present
for getting out of surgery because I was
like my first one I was so freaked out
by it that she gives me one like a dumb
kid I traded it in one day and I was
headed to the day I died the limited
edition Gears of War 1 became this huge
tin mm-hmm it was beautiful playing that
while I was healing up with my best
friend Reuben at the time here's years
of war way she didn't let you watch
wrestling but she gave you get help to
cut school
thing dafif drew I think she just gave
up okay now five you like more like God
like I like fighting it and maybe like
my evilness kind of rubbed off on her
because they nowadays my mom awful yeah
my mom all of his son is like overnight
she's just like instead of being like
this weird yeah satanic Kristin whatever
she was it's like yakichi Gears of War
yes sure I'll get you the only one she
wouldn't get was like Grand Theft Auto
at the time
okay so that was living you definitely
the prosecute you got the Xbox love and
then you got to the channel oh so I
gotta get when this transition happen
then become the PlayStation Trophy gas
guy because like what happened your your
history do you know yeah another podcast
I must go it is so Xbox and that's why
they when it comes to the trophy room I
always played the hardcore fanboy side
as a joke because I know that my history
of PlayStation is somewhat PlayStation 3
but mostly ps4 and that my co-host Kyle
is the person that's in love with
PlayStation like he's never played an
Xbox player even ever oh the next box
ever in a shout-out to who named
engineer I'm down in Japan in greatest
man I've ever met and um and so how that
happens was again huge fanboy like to
his stupid degree and I'm working at
Gamestop and this guy is coming guy
comes in and he's just like yeah there's
so much ps3 he has no controller he has
none of the wires
obviously it smells like weeds he's
probably buying me six dollars yeah no
company protocol
ethology site listen we'll give you 60
bucks for this you need to get the
wiring controller so it's pretty much
useless here's what I'll do just have
the morbid curiosity I just got paid
today I could be 80 bucks for it okay
right got it bought like the wire for
for like five bucks of a controller for
like four thirty so I got my ps3 for
like a hundred twenty bucks and I was
just like okay I'm gonna try this thing
out and whatever this is in the middle
of the PSM blackout remember yes yes yes
I remember
so I played uncharted 2 because my mom I
was asking my Sony Pony friend I'm like
what's a game to get for this I have no
idea whatever bleep right there did you
yeah and so my friends just like start
with uncharted 2 mm-hmm
first ten minutes of uncharted 2 I was
just it blew my mind
mm it was like literally like coming to
Jesus moment of like man hey I've been
thinking this whole time is the dumbest
way of thinking ever so this was a
transformative experience this is when
that single play is so II ps3 exclusives
we're kicking it hard okay so during the
whole month that like the police station
blackout was happening everybody who's
complaining I'm having the time of my
life I'm like I'm sorry too might be one
of the greatest games I've ever played
and I just started playing the whole
backlog of Sony games and it was during
this time we're like I can't even tell
you an accurate number of how many red
rings I had with the xbox360 not a hate
is building but now yeah there's there's
some there's some there's some add four
of them you're good although he woke up
I'm letting this man do his thing I'm
totally at least six you know came down
to the helo reach 360 that red ring that
was the slim version and the person told
me over the phone yeah it still does it
rarely we just removed the red LED I'm
like you guys sure about this I'm a PC
guy mm-hmm I'm playing my ps3 mm-hmm I
played The Last of Us another
come-to-jesus moment
oh my god this is I I know what my
playstation is it's the exclusive
machine right hmm I have this PC I
begrudging Lee hate Xbox but I know I'm
gonna come back to it right I know this
abusive relationship is what it is
mm-hm yeah you know ps4 happens and I'm
just like okay I think I'm gonna get
this console down the line let me just
see what Xbox one has and it's yet
Spotswood launch what it is right Major
Nelson fight show what was it
amy-jo about oh it's you know he's not
lying capability and it's not like
flipping a switch and a week later they
flipped the switch and it was it was it
was how many red rings I've been through
this is deep where you go with this yeah
it was it was feeling a kind of slighted
and betrayed by I've had so many great
memories with but it was over time and I
think that was the straw problem I'm
gonna cut you for a second because I
love hearing your story only from the
simple fact that like you and my opinion
represent what had happened you know at
the start of the of the generation
between the Xbox one and the PlayStation
4 and people don't realize there were a
ton of Lord bad bits that wouldn't prime
before dominantly Xbox guys and you know
it was the consistency option you had
the red ring so that are I mean I can't
combat you like if you having constant
failures with one product you get that I
know a bunch of people that stopped
because of the red ring yeah yeah so you
got the red ring on that then the gen
starts that the befuddled messaging we
got a 360 for you the the DRAM and then
Sony does the most iconic thing shoot
rate games exactly at $400 full $900 see
that part right even hundred now
the part they got everybody over you
know it's one comment on camera that
watches you in exactly but you got a
camera watching you now the people was
fighting for them and when they PSN go
down now me like oh my god no oh when
they xbox live go down oh that's a funny
thing is they Xboxes prediction of the
future either mostly accurate mostly
accurate yeah it was just it was just it
was forced nobody won nobody nobody
wanted to be told what to do not fail
you that's why I brought both yeah you
needed the illusion of choice right yeah
and so like for me getting the
PlayStation 4 I remember the first year
sucked so bad because all these games
that were supposed to be the
revolutionary this I love that you said
that cuz a lot of people forget that I
always make an argument that the Xbox
one launch titles were way strong
resogun for it was it was very indecent
that's that listen yeah
that's around the time Sony was
embracing all the Indies yes because
they had no games
Microsoft had two games and they but
they had no resolution so they had the
resolution was bad man the camera that
was watching it was it was visit a
stupid camera and then sony has the
power because they didn't put the camera
in a box they removed it behind listen
when I get to my part you gonna love it
you don't love this time fall was a game
I really enjoyed by I enjoyed it on my
PC watchdog to remember that and then
even like destiny right we're talk about
a second here was a game that like man
this is how big of a nerd I am
I love Bungie I know their copy
complicated relationship with Microsoft
and so seeing them on stage of the Sony
you know you theme then you know putting
destiny into my playstation
and just seemed to Bungie logo I got
emotional it looks like eight left with
me yeah it confirmed you and I you made
the right choice to move yeah
can I love destiny one as flawed as a
key was it was good I loved it so much
and so you know you're with the right
group of people you're funny so like as
much as I understood it was flawed and
yeah and I definitely agree with with
the criticisms it was still in a game
that I I just have so many good feelings
for then we get to blood-borne game of
the generation oh here we go he starts
alright let's talk about blood ones
let's go you got the Statue let oh yeah
no he's by blood board is a game that
you know back in the day I was just like
I'm a shooter guy yeah I'm a
third-person shooter got strategy games
I don't know how do you think about
these action RPGs Dark Souls is hard
playing that game opened my eyes because
I fell in love with it instantly I was
it's like actually I really like this
challenge actually games the hard it's
just teaching you things without being
overtly like here's the text on abusive
uses Ninja Gaiden was abusive that game
is above bullet abusive like I played
Ninja Gaiden and I hated it because it
was stupid hard and something clicked
with me that was just like like the
first level is perfect I say it every
blood blow on a probably PlayStation
second-best exclusive hell yes it is oh
my god like I got a war all day but
anyway continue
like blood-borne was like it opened my
eyes like this is awesome level design
that this it made me think deeper about
videogames then previous
2015 happens I love overwatch Blizzard
one of my favorite favorite of all well
no I'm going to repeat that talking
about this Kratos or that fate cradles
that you get history does you talk about
black Kratos are you talking about that
other cradles that you get exactly like
he was the first three for the rest of
his existence I can tell you this the
cradles that I want look it was the
greatest we needed the one the credit is
the crazy Minos the cradles you got and
you for the same guy over and over again
had no choice but to take it over watch
captain love it uncharted 4 I very much
enjoyed I don't think it is like oh my
god one of the best PlayStation
exclusives ever just it's good it's just
a little long in the tooth you're
predictable and stuff so I over watching
my game of the year again it's another
like huge love of mine like I love Worf
a good game favorite franchises a long
time overwatch is just like Blizzard
making a shooter makes no sense but I
was so on board and seeing how
successful it was and is still amazing
2017 happens all right Joseph fell out
of love with Nintendo all of a sudden
boom I'm back now we see that's where me
you link right there's when I fell back
in low because I'd stop with them for a
while
stop facts combine all the old Wii U
games you skip like they were damn about
amazing breath a wild amazing game and
at that time you know it overshadowed
horizon zero dawn mm-hm and this is
where the police station at that time
talked about at that time
oh yeah well for me like it was after
III I wasn't feelin horizon buzz it's
like after III after all my coverage I'm
gonna just take a week or two I'm gonna
play horizon zero dawn and it was it was
like one of those games like I always
hear stories of like I wasn't into this
game but then I played it six months
later and I fell in love with it
horizon zero dogs my game of the year
2017 my weapons don't break after five
just don't fall asleep while you clean
breath while either did you have them or
do you had a brethren Wow is everything
everything in there cuz like for me
brother I was been so stuck on destiny
I've missed to me James like I didn't
finish Bertha a while they didn't finish
horizon zero dawn because of me doing
too much destiny so I had my own fault
there but I don't know just to feel like
horizon was cool but when I like stepped
into the world of breath awhile as
results no no open it just something
different to me it's like and I know and
I believe me I have friends that were
like hey breath of the wild was not the
best like hey to the weapons breaking
and stuff like that it's like there were
things that I think could have been
changed but just the open world you
literally you look out to a mountain and
you can go all the way there and you
mind the weapon breaking thing like
that's all I'm gonna actually do is they
break like no I kind of felt like when
you got the Master Sword that shouldn't
I broke at all yeah it rubs or X itself
but I felt like you you should have even
done that if you go through all that
nonsense to get to Master Sword then you
that thing should be invincible feeling
that part I think I think what he is
saying and I got a I got a sham boy out
for 2017 right now go grab a go ahead a
little bit right that is the only reason
why I say a lot of people like you know
and I get it I think it's what he said
it's the open world aspect it's the
first time internals do it but to me
what they did it different because they
had aspects of like portal in that game
but to me the number one thing though is
climbing stuff I mean no more the game
is that like I could scale it you and
I'm saying yeah it just it created an
extra dimension that most 3d games don't
do is it like revolutionary in just that
one aspect no but I think it's like I
said since the car box all the time
I think what made Breathitt a wild go
for me is that it was a marriage of all
these great systems in one game and it
just merged well you know saying that
that's my fight [ __ ] it's it's
definitely I would argue it's probably
now I don't know if I really really
really really like firing moon it's it
it's the top three games on this was
like by far is like it fit that single
game got me into the switch ecosystem
right now facts I'll be that literally
to me I think I told I told the Tenno
girls is I was on the show I said if it
was it for breath of the wild being a
launch channel and as great as it was I
don't know if the switch you and the
purchase it's arguably they can they can
take the success of that game on that I
think that because at the end of the day
like yeah people gave to switch a chance
cuz it launched was probably one of the
best games that came out this generation
shut up good we you to died with one of
the best games ever made
Breathitt well we joke around all the
wild is it is one of if not the most
important exclusive yes ever lost Idol
ever I agree right because that's all
the idea of no no no no no this game is
the same game whether you're playing on
the go or or at home it's the same exact
game and you know the funny thing is
always argue people on the show cause
silver Zoda
it's like people think I hate breath of
the wild for some reason it's like I
never said I didn't
like the game I love breath of the wild
yeah but would you know it does when
you're comparing the Zelda games
together it's like which one it's like
it's like putting masterpieces in a roll
they're all amazing I gotta say this
right now and I really can't take your
word for it
right but what I would do is I will let
the CEO of play craft tell you which is
the best Zelda game and I'm gonna
explain to you when a CEO can itemize
all his games in his little which is the
mash which is thousands of games that he
has played and he have seen and he has
picked this game above all to listen you
know what mouths gonna say quick thing I
just want to like it just gonna go
through every person just say your top
Zelda really quick doesn't matter I'm
just actually really curious because
it's not a guy would sort I'm sorry you
just say that but the Wii U for itself
and I'm gonna tell you look at the sales
numbers on Starwood soared I'm pretty
sure it's very high because that we sold
a hell of a lot in the chat right now
what is the best put it into I got
breath I gave up a Nintendo and that
gave me confidence enough so that for me
look at you
exactly that's the point - one of my
favorite exclusives Nintendo exclusives
ever like I love splatoon so much but
like when I played horizon zero dawn
like the beginning yeah like I get what
people say it's boring or whatever it
would I have you for me as I grow older
I guess my interest is like I want a
really good story and I could character
I could really believe in right and that
was the way
I loved a lawyer I loved her story and I
loved the two arcs at least two
different stories you know hope that was
happening at the same time and at the
end kind of fighting and verging into
one really great great moment and I
ending there hasn't been one scarred
sword in that chat yet her eyes and
effort the same way I think the gameplay
got so honestly for me the gameplay got
so kind of repetitive and boring it was
a story that pushed me through and I
stopped and started that game I don't
know maybe four or five times partially
because the breadth of all the same
thing but I have to say like the story I
told you guys that whole Gaia thing and
what they attempted if you to say that
is amazing that is one of the most
amazing store gardens I've seen ever I
gotta say I got this a moat like I got
so emotional out together I just I
wondered I beat the game and I just
watched the credits I just like know
these people powerful I walked up to my
mother I just think it gave me the
biggest I was thinking like no I love
you so much
nothing not the sidebar but um breath of
the wild is the highest selling selling
Zelda games with eight point four eight
million soul right and Skyward Sword
sold what was it three point four 1
million sold and um as far as you know
because that's a bunch of newbies out
here and playing that game I'm not gonna
lie bref little wild is fantastic but
I'm pretty sure once they do the remake
all you newbies will definitely be able
to throw your little nunchucks and play
Skyward Sword again and they're gonna
bring it out again because I'm asking
for it so the king is gonna get what the
king wants and no play aside what's
going on the switch notice how Skyward
Sword like the only game that's never
talked about remains ever no one is
we make you know what's you know listen
everybody listen not everybody likes
caviar all right not everybody likes you
know the finer things in life
and I'm gonna tell you right now when
you get stuck I would sword you
understand what the finer things in life
is horizon that was just like I need to
make so many podcast right now right
this moment that's what the creation of
the trophy room is um and you know
eventually I had a co-host she decided
to go get married get pregnant have a
kid alright sure do thanks Stephenson
2017 rebranded the whole organization
and from there on out the trophy room is
all about Playstation but with the
acknowledgement that we love all the
other consoles too so I'll make stupid
load the exact consoles but you know I'm
just doing it out of there I'm jesting
gotta respect like I said yeah I've been
on The Oprah Show vcast
that was literally the energy it was
positive you guys welcomed me in because
I had no cash likes Xbox - I was just
like dude we need to talk about gears
were fine we even were five on a
Playstation [ __ ] me so MUC use more fire
that's gonna play I'm not gonna be fake
and tell you I was playing uncharted 3
like you go in warp I'm seriously one of
the best used war games in series but
like though with all that said yeah
that's that's what kind of just started
off was horizon zero dawn and to talk
about God war for a second God of War to
me I've never been a fan of Kratos
couldn't relate to him thought it was a
bit of a d-bag after killing the CEO
family there's just there's no for me
love for that character God of War [ __ ]
God of order of the reboot I I got some
emotional because
for me the relationship credos has with
the Tres well it was a child to be art
or wasn't the child endangerment was it
would be child abuse of the child
intervene on them
no it reminded me of like of how me my
dad interacted and the biskits this is
he's our old-school cool stolen right
stoic I'm not showing you emotions and I
am very emotional I take after my Puerto
Rican mother like that when I'm all now
he's like boy bring me cookies boy why
can't you shoot that arrow there was a
moment of like how how he mourns for for
their mother or trace his mom and bones
coming is yeah
it was kind of like it was the same
interaction I have my dad oh and my
grandpa died and I remember getting into
an argument with him because we had a
lot of family fallout and that what
credo says is that he's just like I'm
more differently than the other I'm
sorry I can't I can't like cry like you
do you know like that's not who I am
don't question that I miss her I miss
her every date other thing that's those
those moments of like just ah hit me
feel so yeah God for is my favorite game
of all time because wall see now you
just transition that's all about there
cuz we got to get the fire move so I
think the thing and first of tremendous
is to me not not to bring a change is
that we little bit behind but um the
thing is is that like you said you said
God war right see that's over so we got
to ask you like we ask every guest in
the room I need that top five oh god
watches her now again to be any order
and it could be franchise as well a
godless I got this
let's go back so yeah God warned number
one okay
Last of Us number two okay Alan I love
The Last of Us - sorry I will have less
- yeah Rhett Red Dead Redemption baby
I'm talking about I've never played
number three and then number four would
have to be hero has to be okay in the
number five did I say blood-borne let's
put blood-borne in there
Wow blood-borne is nice that's
definitely up in there
so that's my favorite games of all time
for sure
tremendous list sir now real quickly
before we move on I know you haven't
been on since we changed our format and
program I think I know two of them so
can i okay
could I could I split two of them that I
think and did you tell me what your five
is oh you want my fire does not say
destiny for one of these he needs to be
good or my coals my best is Chrono
Trigger
that's number one oh man that game is
I'm gonna say I'm not now the next two
I'm not gonna know the order I'm just
gonna say them Super Metroid wrong three
deaths that he gotta be older but again
let's see it could be wrong give me your
top five so destiny has to be on the
list I don't know where chrono trigger
is my number one that will sit there for
probably forever see I'm always torn on
I was like when you were talking about
n64 you had me in the fields as well
because you talk about Nintendo you talk
about their creativity with like 16-bit
cartridges and using songs over and over
at different speeds and all the stuff
they got creative with and when you win
in select I played 8-bit Zelda
I got hooked on NES Zelda the gold
cartridge and everything but but when I
went like Mario 64 was a late revelation
and then the evolution was ocarina of
time in the adventure beyond that so
ocarina of time is on my list my words
soared in there see here's like the
sacrilege thing about that a lot of
people always claim link to the past is
up there and I've never played that well
that's what I've actually got to play so
but like Ocarina of Time for the
adventure and just like my age and
exploring and everything it was just
like that was perfect so Chrono Trigger
ocarina of time destiny has to be on the
list that is definitely there like that
I mean it's been it's been five years
the only other game that I probably
spent as much time as I had with destiny
has been world Warcraft and that was
like my parents that were like 44 days
and just the journey that I'm late I
mean that was years of going through and
that was that was my first like 40
person raid like yes he was not my first
raid world was so it's like you know
come from that world of warcraft was
another like it was a journey and those
were experience like a crazy experience
yeah that's probably one of the most
loved Zelda games you know the least
played Zelda game is probably Skyward
Sword because of the fact that people
were smart to see it look we played see
um you know a lot of people who are like
going against the weak at that point in
time I don't want to play don't we I
don't want to be swinging no thing and
once I saw that Zelda you were able to
actually have the one-on-one ratio of
swinging I'm sorry that whole thing to
me I've always want to swing the sword
if it's if it's the case of that then
why did white princess do well well
Twilight Princess did well because
people like you that didn't want to use
your arms you didn't want to swing your
sword so you know you said then use like
I'm a button press and you know if it
fit for you like for like so so it's
skyress or Castilla you know the
exception but for some reason you know
Twilight Princess didn't have that issue
I don't know that Skyward Sword you
wanna play Skyward Sword together
they're the be-all end-all but I Jian
still gave Skyward Sword of ten
everything you did you could think of
the desert upset continued but I always
get those like in King's defense
actually in playing Skyward Sword yeah
like I don't know if people did or
didn't like it like it was just one of
like I fell off time but I was actually
really enjoying the game so it's like I
don't have anything against Skyward
Sword ocarina is just specials but if
you finish it I admit I haven't finished
a lot of games my brother gives me crap
all by herself
I'm sorry that man got other things on
his mind
sorry he got things he got a duty
knievel Skyward Sword sir I got like a
crew behind me right now I got no I
remember that time I looked at your
channel ACOG said you look look you got
a look at this guy and I'm like okay let
me tune and I looked and I saw you
soloing and nightfall I'm like this
guy's crazy
I call for help ahead of time like I
have like friends this guy's like I
don't see my like my like somewhere in
the middle it's like and then it's like
like 1 & 2 like Chrono Trigger
I think Legend of Zelda are probably
there below that as always stuff that
has been in different places and kind of
in flux because I mean you said Super
Metroid which was an amazing game I
loved the exploration for me it almost
might be the world of like learning
challenges which has got me into like
blood-borne and Dark Souls and things
like that is something all the way back
to Mega Man 3
so like Mega Man 3 was one of those
games that I've straight-up
finished whole thing full completion and
that's one of those games that you know
you missed two jumps you start the whole
damn level over and you're just screwed
so it's brutal but that's one of those
that taught and it's they had to make
him difficult because they were short
they didn't have as much as based on
that as much memory and things like that
so now if Mega Man 3 probably has what
got me to like many further games in the
future that have been challenging that
has pushed me to do nightfall solos and
stupid crap like that but I'm like why
am I going to do this because I want to
I want to have the challenge I don't be
like can I do this okay I think I can do
this okay and then I finally did it and
then now my youtube channels like can I
show other people how to do it so it's
been an evolution but yeah Megaman 3
Super Metroid Dark Souls like there's a
whole genre in there that's like
challenging games for me but I know you
that's how I seen the development with
the blood-borne I know you a bad [ __ ]
share that you know saying and then like
I seen you with the sucker I was really
good yeah I've seen you struggle in that
game and I beat the last boss before you
we all love games that's all starfox
over there man oh so many so many good
games you can't be wrong oh man all
right the winner all right let's get
into last week's poll winner we got that
going on to the question with their
recent announcement by naughty dog The
Last of Us - will not launch with
multiplayer and instead have a separate
multi player factions mode at a later
date do you agree with the decision
reason given by the developer the winner
of a runaway landslide three-way IOP
poll at 73% is the yes Last of Us single
players should be made priority and not
worry about attack dog multiplayer
experienced group coming I agree with
the poll
I bet you voted covenant at second place
at only 16 percent was the no lack of
transparency and just an excuse to
monetize and ship a game with less
features group and at last place at a
close 10 percent plus the I don't care
so da got no boat should be going to
last of us waiting five six years for
the last of us go play multiplayer just
just wait for it it's coming and the
second one though of it with that I
don't care that you know full well that
whatever you get in multiplayer is gonna
be super robust you're gonna pay some
things but yeah let me just ask a better
question to King about this and more
caught me because we know a song don't
play destiny but let's say destiny three
drops that are like we gonna launch the
multiplayer later what the hell it's the
same with CD Projekt RED what they're
doing with cyberpunk 2080 first well I
think it's I think is no Babbitt I do
see your point but the difference is I
think the mistake they made is they
should have been transparent from the
beginning like cyberpunk immediate just
came out so late and I think that was
what the surprise because initially they
did say multiplayer was gonna be part of
it so I think that's what really got
people of it so even if they you said
it's multiplayer could be a thing or not
like I'm super soon I think that this if
you look at their Twitter they're
posting job like they're literally
retweeting then pull getting job
listings like like they're trying to
prove to people with certain baby but
they did that six months ago nobody but
why would a dev come out
openly in an interview and say we
focused on a single player entity
entirely and the game they came out
later after that it said okay no we
don't know what they were talking about
yes we have a multiplayer in LA no no
because I like straight up like even
even oh god the co-creator stealing even
said like dude I've seen it it's there
it exists but developers are constantly
hiring again before this big
announcement like six months ago there
was job listings for multiplayer level
designers but we don't know if that's
for if there was for last it was - we
don't we don't even know if this will be
a last to lose to a game I mean I mean
the Optus it could be an apex legend
seeing with completely unrelated to the
game itself
I don't think Naughty Dog's hiring
anybody true but one thing we can agree
on we can agree on one thing that
they're gonna make you pay for it
separately and you know the Sheep who's
gonna go buy it we'll see ya at the end
of the day you let people believe for
years that this was coming out and if
you didn't clarify that it was or was
not coming out until you started getting
attacked you didn't even tell people
yourself people have every right to be
upset with Naughty Dog right it's like
right it's like it's it's it's like
right now everyone that plays destiny -
assumes there's gonna be a multiplayer
for destiny 3 so if they all of a sudden
doesn't have her it doesn't look like if
you have a huge demographic of people
assumed then why would you let that go
with or without it he said to fake I
don't care Christopher Hart says listen
to the arena champ is not in color Oh
guys my one question is like did they
ever say it was gonna have multiplayer
yes okay well then if they said that and
they change their mind and that's a you
know difference of things but it's also
I mean yeah they can
that's a game developer choosing to
change their mind or that and that's the
point where I was wondering honestly I
didn't know because if they never said
it before then that's a then you know
expectations were there but also what
has last of us like mostly known for I
get these dory
destiny 3 yeah you have every right to
have be outraged the game is a
multiplayer game
sherry was his single play experience
listen I would be appalled
honestly if destiny became I never like
yeah there's no more people I mean that
dead right there would not have and as
this idiocy that would that one go down
so it's an apple so orange comparison it
doesn't mean ice well why don't you put
up like listen I don't want to say look
like the previous one had this yes it's
like it's like purchasable destiny what
a destiny to it what doing good
there's no create people assume it's
going to be on it then you have to
clarify if it is or is not is the game
out yet is the game out yet we needed
they already said that what do you this
is this is the problem this is the
problem if I purchase the first one and
have multiplayer in the equation or not
I don't care it came with I don't want
to buy a car diamond and get less apart
me the multiplayer players needed six
months to be able to absorb the fact
that now I get a multiplayer launch they
needed all that time like three four
months it doesn't matter why they didn't
explain to me then explain to me why
didn't they say this why they let the me
know three really sucks because it
didn't have dead space Institute
multiplayer you sure the singers in
territory there's a different for that
moment they clarified within hours
afterwards there is a multiplayer
component they've been hiring people for
multiplayer
months before that doesn't mean that
they're working on the multi where for
that individual game so why would they
hire someone for multiplayer and then
let's go oh yeah and you're working on
nobody dog is working on a PS 5 game
they clarified that before hopefully it
does come out hopefully they do give it
to you for free
hopefully last of us broke out again or
stitch with
super champion is in the Stone Age so
why make a multi-player if the network
is so far behind think about Oh anyway
here we go we got some tops to get into
now obviously you know the realm they've
been waiting for the king and we're
going to let him loose but before then
Lord saw let's set the stage obviously
there's been a lot of things going on as
far as on Sony as far as reshuffling
unless you say right yesterday yeah
let's get to it
let's get a couple of things in the in
the land of PlayStation this week so
first before we get to the the big one
well they both be so PS now which has
traditionally been $20 a month up until
now all of a sudden had a massive price
drop half of it as a matter of fact so
PS now is now $10 a month in addition to
that they've added four first-party
games to the to the lineup and they've
also add a grant that Thoreau 5s which
are games that now can be downloaded in
addition to streamed on PC which is
something that people thought would not
happen
so already so I mean I don't understand
why people to think this might not
happen
it was exactly bloody pour out of touch
they in exactly but that's what I'm
saying there's plenty of people who said
you know they're not gonna do that to
God of War right you know and there's
plenty I was on Twitter just looking at
it have you ever audibly heard a stutter
in a tweet like that I've heard people
stuttering as they tried to figure out
why this happened right so it's very
interesting because again once again
they're shown that they need to double
down I'll cloud gaming justice you know
that the threat of X cloud has come in
the threat of stadia is coming so that's
very interesting in it of itself
secondly so it was announced again
through a tweet that Shawn Layden the
head of Sony worldwide studios is
leaving PlayStation so that in it of
itself if people leave all the time the
with this is that a was announced in a
tweet and B since it was announced it
wasn't any sort of form oil again it was
it was it was so nice Twitter account
obviously but it wasn't announced in a
formal way
and beyond that since that announcement
there's been no follow-up from anyone
Shawn Layden has been quiet the rest of
Stoney has been quiet it's been left up
to us to speculate what's going on and
they've been a number of different
theories as to why this happened
one theory is that there is internal
strife within Sony if you think about
Shawn Layton's trajectory in the company
he's been in the company over 30 years
it's kind of crazy and I'm not dating
get a gold watch they'd made a tweet
made a PR track that Ladin hasn't
addressed it either makes it feel like
they told him okay you need to shut up
which is weird here son is mea don't say
nothing wrong that's exactly what it is
it's an N right when she's made oh very
much assume he's going to a competitor
so there are a lot of theories as to
what's going on so you know like I said
we'll we'll break those down because I
know people have different theories on
this so that is the framing in what is
going on do we have that backdrop do we
have that picture we have that picture
right right before Lord fill Dominus
Maximus Sloane to be a really a Spencer
took the stage and uh he exit out the
two guys are standing like some do we
have two for those people that have
forgotten what I told you will come to
pass I told you I am a guy of cemetery
and of visuals and when Phil Dominus
Maximus Spencer stepped on the stage he
slept there with a gleeful face and he
looked to his left and he looked to his
right and showed that picture thank you
sir
thank you there we go thank you I want
you guys to look at this fondly as the
person in the middle is the cheese
standing alone all right
so what he did was first person to go to
fall on that sword was Reggie now I want
you guys to keep the same energy because
at any time had filled Dominus Maximus
Spencer left his post he left his post
at any time you guys will be ripping me
a new one so Reggie is gone let's
clarify but you let's clarify because
you had a theory and we yes we must
admit the lords I laughed hysterically
so again Reggie is gone
so it comes to us this week that mr.
Laden himself the lone of the person in
that picture
other than film Maximus insa is gone and
he stands alone so this is this is pre
snap okay post snap this is what happens
right we've noticed that everybody's
been having to work together the only
person that's actually there that's a
part of unity is still standing there
you understand
so the other dudes did not want to play
ball so you don't want to play ball you
gotta go but at the same time I want you
to understand a couple of things right
it's kind of funny soon as mr. Laden is
gone dismissed he leaves via tweet cross
play is enabled that is so you mean the
clouds actually work that the power of
the cloud has eliminated they no longer
care about the protection of the
PlayStation community they can be
unprotected now what has happened right
and I've noticed something PlayStation
now prices it's always got a right
though that is kind of contradicting
everything they've ever said this is the
place they should now prices has dropped
and now you get your exclusive that you
can play on a PC o PlayStation fans are
going crazy mm-hmm I can play my game
someplace else
mm-hmm now I've noticed Christopher Hart
say isn't that date and date not yet sir
at this point in time you understand
when the ship is sinking when they this
sinking listen you've made your bones
off of the unit's that was sold it sold
125 million grand you're doing such a
great job this is fantastic your wedding
if you're winning
how come Microsoft is making the same
amount of money we have the system sold
the sake of balance and fairness i what
to say okay now with the Reggie thing
your theory was Reggie did not want to
go along with that services and and you
know game pass eventually of being on
his platform which is led to his
dismissal now sure lady do you also feel
that Shawn was not in conjunction in
line with this thinking of services and
in cloud is that okay where your
language Shawn listen let me explain
right see with Nintendo they tend to
cover they dirt up a little bit better
as much tact so the guy wasn't out of
office a day
well they said oh by the way um we're
gonna cut the prices on this and I'm
gonna definitely our move that oh yeah
we don't play together with these guys
so you mean the only obstacle could have
been mr. Layton I don't want to play
with them we don't have no need to but
the figures show otherwise sir the rumor
is there is a power struggle between
Ronnie yes and Layton and Ryan in your
defense is Pro cloud is your parole
streaming and you know the vibe we got
shout to the I believe is the game biz
article and I believe the back bed had
been uh the whole dad did you had a
great podcast on this in reference to
that was that you know he seemed to be
old Slavin seem to be old school
PlayStation and he was definitely
sponsible for a lot of the golden years
a lot of the great exclusives that were
acquired and stuff like that and I will
admit it does seem abrupt you know say
so do you are you saying king that Ryan
is in conjunction with I'm saying mr.
Bowser mr. Brian very like play ball and
Phil Dominus Spencer knows he's gonna
pitch that ball you better make sure
that you ready to play right so yes I
honestly believe that these individuals
wasn't down for that listen i'ma tell
you right now I believe Reggie was an
old-school dude he said I'm not playing
with you guys like that that's not gonna
go down like that we go down to the
fanfare to the fight see looking at
old-school people that have these
old-school ways and he's stuck in these
old-school traditions no no going
forward these systems need to be online
they need clouds they need they need
structure they need to be streaming come
on guys you see stadia alright you
understand the debate guy in the room
maybe he doesn't got his footing
together so we have to hit him while
he's off balance
that's exactly yeah so if you're not
willing to play you're willing to stay
stuck in the mud so listen I'm gonna say
something that's highly controversial
right now
- you guys never been a good leader
never all right let me tell you why
they've never been a good leader tell me
what things has are they done to
innovate they've often copied and
imitate we actually done it to the
extent that had you fooled they'll trick
pony so if they're gonna keep doing the
same exact thing expecting different
results they're gonna fail horribly so
you can't take the same ideal of a
single-player experience into the future
where multiplayer experiences is
building operations you have to
understand you have to evolve if you do
not evolve
you will definitely go to where the
dinosaur so individuals that were on
that stage let's not talk anything about
future but the one person in the middle
who has been the constant talking about
unity future and vision is still there
before we get back in response I want to
get these super chats shout to stitch
with the to our super chat King has
always been up to something hot Oh Lord
addict do you want to get JD gamer here
we go foo we've got to find out super
chat from JD it's official future that
others weren't willing to embrace the
other two were caught up in ancient
console war well phil was fill in
microsoft's pockets okay you know what
JD you're onto something know what solve
do you want to get brat super Jensen
said outs of Lord rapper to to us who
preached at the real Phil works for
Google stadia their auto fuel pockets
are let's get to it man what do you feel
what's going on Israel simple that Laden
didn't want to play ball no I think
that's it so first and foremost again
I'm the PlayStation guy so I have to
hate everything Mike
does not not the case what Phil Spencer
has done with the Xbox brand he's
stellar phenomenal without him I don't
think I think Microsoft would have told
the Xbox division long ago it's his it's
his way of thinking of like yeah the
counselor mentality is stupid I hate
when people argue like please we should
still Matt's boss the way to go vice
versa I hate that and so does Phil Phil
wants to break down those barriers the
future of that's box is in game pass
that is what is going to be printing
them money that Netflix future if it'll
seize that though sees this sounds an
opportunity that these games can sell
this this this this brand of game pass
so do I think there's a power struggle I
don't know I think what it is is a
restructuring you know Ryan I have this
quote right here the track record of the
incumbent platform winning the next time
around is not a great one Ryan says so
the major thrust of my executive energy
is to avoid complacency and PlayStation
has been complacent right we're seeing
Microsoft do strides across play cross
progression game pass cloud streaming
and we're seeing police station rust on
the laurels of having really really good
exclusives right so the past year yeah
Charlene has not been in control of the
day-to-day operations of PlayStation
[ __ ] Jim Ryan has and Jon Coderre
have been so we saw the last year jagged
era take Layden's
job essentially and then back away from
it saying you know what I'm going to fix
PSN because it's a mess and Jim Ryan a
person who listened he says dumb crap he
the camera focus on when he's on live TV
but he knows how to sell product when
PlayStation 3 was let's be honest the
PlayStation 3 he would be able to make
that thing sell in Europe so he knows
how to sell a service he knows how to
sell a console and Shawn Layden and
Shawn would never lie to me Laden knows
how to make a kink right so Charlie did
job from what I got from from the read
here was that that position was actually
made
listen just make sure that our games are
good right and so Charlie the job was
like make sure the games are decent
Ryan's job is make sure we sell systems
and Coderre is just like let's make the
PSN functional and that's what I see
this is a structure and gives me prompt
like promise as for the body but you
know there's a lot like that the problem
with that is yeah especially for Laden
is dead okay
they gave him this this job as the as
the head of worldwide studios but that's
after he held the job of CEO of Sony
Computer Entertainment so if anything I
don't care how you restructured how you
word how you put it together it's a he
got demoted oh yeah is he the one who
just now signed up for PlayStation now
after they cut no you know right that
was one of the CEOs one of the head guys
that didn't have the services of this
the platform that they work for do you
mean to tell me the CEO of Toyota drives
an Audi all the workers inside Microsoft
have either game pass or xbox live
though I mean my my thing is like I'll
talked about this internal strife in the
background of course there's gonna be
internal strife that we don't support
the products that you have let's not
throw shade there because he's filter
devaluing Xbox when he's saying how
awesome PlayStation 5 is and that he's
playing no or where would I like you
borrow like you know no no this is when
he's playing god of war on no no no no
but he's trying to tell you is he's a
gamer yeah right and he's trying to tell
you that I purchased a system that even
your own CEO hasn't purchased oh oh so
when he sees the value in your own stuff
that you don't see don't you want that
guy in the middle that's why he's in the
middle of that picture those other two
guys are gone I want a guy that knows
how to run a business right right I
don't want to I don't want a friend
let's say you say Phil Phil doesn't know
how to run a business but you just focus
on the edge of death and then Phil
brought them back but these do
individuals have been complacent so
which one is it sir no what I'm saying
is listen I'm not here to defend
PlayStation right
they have been completed it's just just
just real quick you guys I'm super
jealous we got a $10 super chair from JD
gamer that would take facts so some
facts they need to know Sony is a mimic
a boss topic you copied it Tino's
controller Sega's edge for a master then
Microsoft's playbook for the 360 you
know what you know that you know we
usually do this a justice just for life
but you really might be on to something
like the Victor out steam with the $2
suit which had 10 points King
all right Katina let that Bab it with
your buddy and we gotta get Ibaka say
yeah yeah well I set out to one bad
mother-- with the five it out of super
chat plastic walls will be the
horse-and-buggy of gaming barriers to
afford being able to play in multiple
ecosystems are coming down shall we go
one more shot the BRABUS the Chazz
litany well finalists super Jack King of
course Microsoft employees have Xbox
services because consoles etc they need
all the countries they gotta get those
reporting numbers actually what do I be
onto something that I do have like
actual I dish when you get there when
you were when your employee there like
if you don't get their service for there
cuz you get this for free
mm-hmm you have to actually sign a piece
of paper we're asking why because what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to play numbers mm-hmm okay all right
now we gotta get bad baits rebuttal yeah
and then we get come on beverage oh yeah
no I listen it's not the greatest PR
thing for for someone an exacta go oh
yeah I just bought PlayStation now I get
what they're trying to do as it like a
PR guy they're trying to show you that
hey it's hip to go out here and buy PS
now right now but that wasn't the best
way to go right so yeah and again and at
the same exact time
like I love Phil Spencer he's a I think
he's probably a great dude
yeah you said water Fred you you saying
you know what's funny some people that
way about Phil okay they say that he's a
little too friendly whatever but into
Kings defense you know saying that we
all know the state of Microsoft at the
end I mean at the start of the Xbox one
generation yeah and like you said bad
bit the tremendous job of turning around
something that potentially could have
been dead in the water and he had to
present to Sasha to say look we gotta
invest we if we're gonna take this thing
seriously we gotta go oh I mean there
was like yeah he had a quote about with
with with the CEO Microsoft with like
okay look like they sat down he's like
what's the future of Xbox and after that
that's when he got that position of CEO
that's the vets box so like my dough
gets it because he's a developer and so
he understands the encourage the I can't
say that way he knows the ins and outs
of what makes a game in a platform I
think it's very interesting this see
Sony finally do a 180 on so many things
that they've constantly kind of talk
about now right it should know to like
cross great stuff because they see the
other person stadia enter the room so
they need to think fast because yeah
they've been complacent and yes
everybody copies each other guys yes
what companies do I just got dark mood
on my iPhone gonna say Apple about cuz
they'll do it all top companies cop each
other the only goal is to make money
they couldn't care less what your
opinion is as long as you spend money
bonding up as far as Sony the state of
it and obviously you know executives in
Sean Lena situation you know how you
feeling about this like are you
concerned where are you with Sony
heading into the next gen I mean I'm
happy to see this because I mean you
guys have said it all pretty well it's
like I mean even the was a Jim Ryan at
his position at this point but you
saying they're getting complacent that's
something you don't want to do because
they every every console generation they
keep bouncing back and forth because
somebody's like oh good no you're not oh
good no you're not
you don't want to make those mistakes
cuz that's a really bad idea to do I
just think like I played Gears of War
straight up on game pass it was like my
but I think my buddy told me like game
pass was two dollars for that PC trial
played Gears of War and I was like holy
crap like that's cool played it for you
know it's like two months two dollars
was like damn that's actually really
really cool so that was actually my
first foray into game pass and it's a
really nice thing to see PlayStation
trying to get more on board with
something like that and I think Xbox
game pest is a really solid product that
they've got mine is actually more of a
completely different question because
whether like I mean whether Sony's
finally getting on board a foot you know
Xbox has been doing fill Dominus sitting
on stage you know knocking off both of
those other two people it's like playing
slowly Hans's BAM one it's like those
two guys have been in I think those two
guys whether he's been a developer or
not they've been in their positions and
with those companies for so long it's
like at some point different visions may
happen but it does sound like the Shawn
Layden things got some sketch to it yeah
I definitely think the way they nd8 like
that he's definitely under NDA yeah
definitely in a competitor state and I
think stadium needs someone like him so
it makes sense okay well we all know
that when you go at one of these
companies you have a non-compete clause
right and when you leave these companies
the non complete cause could be for a
year to five years right we don't know
like what his deal is what he signed and
how it goes but I don't see him
transitioning over the stadium which is
probably the cuckoo that's out there
that everybody wants I don't even know
why anybody wants that but the fact that
I matter is this that man left under
mysterious circumstances and at the same
time that he left I mean listen at the
same time he woke up in the morning he's
fired or something something happened
that he's not there
okay we can all say that but we can also
say at the same time the moment he
turned around before the door hit him in
his back you know they already cut the
price down on PlayStation now they're
already playing hands they shown hands
people holding hands now we can play
together like this guy was the only
reason
we couldn't do only you only really see
stuff like that when someone leaves and
I mean this isn't like small changes
this major changes price points across
play like you only really see stuff like
this when someone leaves is the person
who got that position afterwards wanted
to do it all along but the moment that
dude was out the door he's like even
even wait right play it was blue like
the last thing he worked on was the
agreement to get insomniac so I think
like all these things are not like
something you know Jim Ryun woke up I
said you know what cross-play breakfast
we announced it this is London but I'm
working at paperwork looking at an excel
sheet figuring out what works I think
you know Shawn will never lie to me
later he's been having a game for so
long in terms of day-to-day operations
that I think it's more coincidence than
anything else that's a hell of a
coincidence sir we got 99 people 100
people in there let's listen like we
have you know great guests on the show
let's get in this Wow Cedric what's up
you say anything yeah my question like
yeah it's like I mean Sony get onboard
is good for next generation cross-play
is good for everybody
Shawn Layden's departure may have been
one of those things that finally just
needed to happen if that may have been
one of those things that I mean that's
like Shawn Layton's always been like you
seems like a reasonable guy but it's
like if those things happened that
quickly there that is something to be
said for that but my question actually
comes back to PlayStation now game pass
and these types of things when you talk
about and this is just like a whole ball
of wax for another day I'm sure but when
I sit there and I play Gears of War for
$2 or you know I get PlayStation now and
I get it for $9.99 I can play Gears of
War I always wonder about like the cost
of video games because we were talking
about nostalgically like in 64 games
were like 70 or 80 dollars they were a
point where they were really expensive
where does everyone end up valuing video
games when everybody has this just like
subscription model to it I always wonder
like
how the developers are able to make
money or what these agreements
behind-the-scenes out what are the
finances of game pause cat pass I'd
really be curious to see like how game
pass works how that's distributed like
how that works is I was wonder where
that's gonna go that's just a big
question in my mind because all this
stuff always brings up like the value of
a game cuz when I play something for two
dollars or ten dollars how does that
make me value a $60 game anywhere like
they should they cost more to make now
than they ever have and they're cheaper
now than they ever have it's just weird
and I think those those questions are
going to get answered while we
transition into this next generation
that's why I feel - I think it's one of
those things that again I'll jump in
real quick and I know I'm gonna get the
rest of loads in is that at this point
The Vow the vibe I'm getting from both
is they want to lock people into their
control systems cost and at an issue
maybe short end sacrifice of a Gears v
as you know I'm saying $60 gaming we got
like now
PlayStation now doing got a war in there
they're doing you know Grand Theft Auto
5 you know it's real exclusives inside
this service so the vibe I'm getting
with cloud streaming and all this stuff
is that they're trying to get you locked
in so that once you're locked into the
ecosystem coming to the next generation
where the extreme intense off or not you
know I'm saying they can put them way
they look I feel they look at it ears
they'll rather have your reoccurring 15
to 20 dollars or whatever it is per
month then the option of maybe you buy
the $60 game or maybe you not so it goes
from the millions to the billions right
right and then you go in the billions to
people in regions that let's be honest
like you know Japan and more in a mobile
market you see Microsoft doing what
they're doing with China with SK Telecom
and those kind of deals they are
concerned about that mobile market and
people who would never traditionally buy
a console so that's more gaming so I
think the vibe I think is maybe the long
play and maybe financially if the books
get in covered we see like right now
they're taking the short-term loss who
knows but I think that's what it seems
you know the vibe is so far let's get us
solve in as well well if you look at if
you look at Sony jumping into this right
and you you wonder what do they have to
gain when they're selling 12
10 12 15 million copies of that of the
number-one franchises right what do they
have to gain at the end of the day
though if you look at 6 months away from
from from launch of any one of these
games those games are selling for half
the price if not less than that right
visible profits right what if you buy so
they think it is if you get a
subscription model for your PlayStation
ecosystem and you're paying 10 bucks a
month and to have access to all these
games which is another thing we haven't
said yet that you know they put they put
first party games in there they have yet
to say they're gonna put a first party
game day in date
launching could be for a while but I
don't wish they're gonna have an you
arey that's another thing they're
actually removing their first party
games from the service or rotating them
with this weird I would say just keep
them in there but for me I think if in
the long term if you're gonna continue
to make money off these single put
experiences out I don't care how great
they are
you're gonna play them once you're gonna
play them maybe twice and then you're
now playing them again right the more
you get that platinum you sell them
you're done so it's one of those things
how do you continue to make money off
what is their biggest strength and I
think they'll continue to be the biggest
drink is a single-player experience
that'll continue to be that so I think
it makes a lot of sense for them to go
this route and then obviously build on
some sort of multiplayer that no people
have been asking for look we need we
need strength in this area it's coming
right so it's absolutely something that
I think I'm glad it's happening the
stuff that's happening behind the scenes
a song I really do think that this Shawn
Layden for whatever reason he was he was
not happy about where things are going
and you know you you got demoted
honestly you got demoted and you can you
cut that any which way you want I
wouldn't be happy if I got demoted you
know what I kind of want to bring up
just a little bit yeah uh you know Shawn
Leighton we would say he he's a dude
that leaves and it can seriously impact
things can we not agree oh absolutely
that one that dude left from know like
what is it
that wasn't an issue that was a huge
issue but when people even shot Layton
people know the face of the brand to the
creative director of huge entity people
that could possibly influence a brand
and no one's acting like this is an
endpoint according to you he wasn't huge
a quote sovereign two to two addicts
defense and I will always jump to his
defense on that thing is when at
Microsoft Stubbs their toe it's a huge
problem sure
Sony can fracture their arm lose a limb
and it's like well you know those things
happen where the countless articles will
I might be worried about Sony Sony's
direction of where its own you're gonna
go mad I've seen the thumbnails right
now like yeah we didn't like scaling it
but is somebody saying he's not gonna
buy us PlayStation 5 because it is
exactly how Phil pad you woke up
tomorrow and Phil is gone comparing it
to different yes and this is one see
what anak is trying to say is
Microsoft's head of 343 when he left you
know everybody had this big uproar right
and he's wasn't what Eric is saying he's
not as big as mr. Laden you understand
and this he's trying to figure out where
the hell is all that energy that all
that anger all that furor
but where's all that ruin abyss remember
the conversation around the halo thing
right we said halo Infinite is the most
important game coming into next
generation for for the success of the
new Xbox
Platinum right it's it's launching Dane
day and it's super important more than
this to do it arguably is the reason the
Playstations okay and did this is what
I'm addict is telling you to the truth
that's the truth right there he just
said this man is intrical to going into
launching a new platform and he is out
the door and all the philosophies change
at the end of the day if if it needed to
happen now's the best time but is that
not troublesome nation going into the
next situation are you nervous about
cyber because they lost creative
directly question I guess where my
concern I guess my little you know red
light for light or whatever it is is
just that we've heard Jack Trenton Nick
Sutter Adam boys yeah that's real
concern lated so so mile again is it you
know the house is on fire completely I
don't know but again to keep I just
don't see the same concerned we're
talking about a whole company versus a
studio yes I won't raise I will these
departures right all I'm saying
this I will say I think Sony beyond the
above Microsoft and above Nintendo is
devaluing that face of the brand thing
yeah more and more like because nobody's
nobody was really like Trenton right
right nobody would be like trying right
oh boy Shuhei Yoshida had it for a while
and they just put him in the back but
they said go away for what every let me
play that was a go let me reverse it
what departure would get you concerned
what what what would have to happen that
you would wake up and you look at Sony
differently because I think that's
commune where addict and king are going
because they're I'm again I just get I
just get tired of people send that every
time you make any kind of allegation
every time you make any kind of example
people like oh no that that's not gonna
happen this is gonna happen people say
you know PS now they're gonna put first
party in there oh that's not gonna
happen they first party and they're
people act like they never
that's the my boys hack to campaign for
gears five four months and you didn't
see none of those videos say you know I
was wrong
it was a good campaign none of that
stuff like I'm tired of it like I really
and truly and we know how you feel about
this thing about it is in wait just like
King said when Layton left everything
fell into place right we knew exactly
where they wanted to go like let's say
all that right no no you put it when I'm
saying is that when he left they were
definitive decisions made about the the
PlayStation is going definitive
decisions this is not something that
we're hearing Oh everything is up in the
air we don't know we don't know you're
not getting back allegations that you
don't mess with same when you can make
allegations that you do know and then we
know he left the only thing I would say
that it's spooky the way he left the way
he left is spooky did it leave me
feeling like PlayStation is in shambles
no now why not see see this is why BBC
said we're doing this we immediately
said we're doing a B and C okay so
there's so somber thing is the whole
direction moving forward after this
happened what's cool you know it's funny
King Microsoft buys five studios and
they showed allegations they show the
direction of the studios they're gonna
be doing you know we need to see these
games
okay oh my god you I don't know where
you pull your comparisons from you
that's how you free games you spend in
the game I think game Pass makes more
money for the devs okay bad bits off I
want to get on the end one of the things
how devs make money off game paths is
the deals that are being had it's one of
the comparisons I made on the trophy
room this week for example Epic Games
paid for exclusive marketing rights or
not marketing rights but a exclusive to
the epic game store they paid ten
million dollars for that so we can
assume that Xbox game pass is giving
monies to these developers to have some
type of it's 19 million dollars for full
of Devil May Cry 5 yeah so deaths are
making money on these games and that's
fine you know when it comes to why are
we not panicked yet yes because we
haven't because there is there's no
reason to once we see the mess up
starting to happen that's when we start
getting concerned like no one was
concerned about the Xbox one X in all
their games Xbox one launch right and
then these they tripped and fell down
that mountain right once once dude once
Jim Ryan chips on that shrub then we're
starting starting right now what you're
saying is the cachet is so high right
now
exactly yeah - you see right the thing
that makes me laugh is that you're
saying okay look so Godward Last of Us
it's almost impossible than for the mess
80 you put a million lives in my mouth
yo adding you you're the worst debater
ever ever what we've been saying is that
since Laden is gone
they followed they've copied whatever
they follow super what Microsoft is
doing that we've all agreed is the way
to go so now you say they're in trouble
because they're following what we agreed
is the way to go you understand if they
continue to fight against that and
somehow that's not to what they're doing
then I'd be worried but again the moment
he walks out the door and I'm not saying
this is the reason but the moment he
walks out the door all of these things
that we said it should happen a long
time ago what happened continue all
right so you guys say you're not worried
if we all sit in an office structure and
we in our cubicles and I see people get
up leaving one by one you think I'm
gonna be the last person sitting in that
damn room waiting for the building to
fall down or some a fire to happen or
some contagion to go through no you
understand when the first person gets up
my my intent is it's not layoffs it's
one person yeah I me concerned about
Nintendo because they got I'm terribly
concerned about Nintendo I'm terribly
concerned the question I posed and you
make it a good I know what you guys are
I get both sides of it this is really a
gesture yeah but the thing is I guess
where I where I struggle a little bit is
we know how dominant they've been we
know success where they've been but at
the same time they are now prepping for
the start of a new generation right we
are hearing rumors from developers
saying that we are extremely nervous we
have not gotten deaf kids you know I'm
saying so there is some effect of this
internal struggle whatever it is that's
going on behind the scenes that is
having an effect on the development of
PlayStation 5 we've seen that on the
game there's articles they like yo we
are very concerned now
- your defense solve yes there's a
direction immediately after late in you
know services cloud okay I get that but
I think to King's defense it's like you
know when PlayStation five launches
right you know how are we going to look
at them if like I said this thing
continues right if this if we keep
hearing more kind of stuff like this or
just in general like you I guess to your
point is you guys just want to wait
until there's no quality games well I
guess when is that moment of fear where
does that bow it for the diehards to say
yo this don't look right Star Wars they
can't do their whole philosophy is now
in line with the people well this is for
the fanboys your whole philosophy now is
the the console each you don't like your
whole philosophy right now is
Microsoft's philosophy you have did a
180 sir and flipped to the other side
now now you want to do put your first
party games in your service now you want
to cross play now you want to do all
these things that shall raged about and
thought about and screamed about a
yelled about they'll even actually have
service from Microsoft at one point in
time are you gonna put that X on your
box and stop calling to the place okay
like that's a crazy thing that I talked
about earlier it's like a lot of what
the original X boxes message was
eventually happen you know it was it was
that they were correct if where the
future was but they wanted the future
right now you know we were going on with
this I'll finish you know at the end of
the day the keys data Jim right now you
know I'm saying so you got rules the
true you got showing up out of there you
know is there he's a welcome his his
vision his vision
his vision is alive with how we build
ominous smackdown it's a really a spin
sir winsome
you know when there really is comes
there really is comes when the next
generation launches and that game passes
on that PlayStation and that's when I do
this when game pass comes it's gonna be
great
III think it's it's a matter of time
well yeah I would love that I would love
that
Tan's we got to see what's gonna happen
you know um if these moves end up being
the right moves um at the end of the day
my only beautiful Ryan's kind of a
Babbage said in the past he has made
statements there baby oh my eyes you
know about not like valuing who wants
backward compatibility I don't know the
best to do you want to be have out there
on a stage talking about stuff I don't
know yeah I don't know we got it we
gotta get in fairness we got it we got
to give him his thing but yeah there's
some questionable things there yeah you
know I like his move so far though I
know you like I mean his moves his his
day one move like okay so what we're
gonna do here is you guys can play with
you guys
cut half price half price on a
Playstation now that's a little bit too
much bro that's a little bit too much
put on a Warren there let's sell this
thing let's go baby
I'm with this dude he likes to party I
like that I've had it with a couple of
people said the little files are very
low but I've been around a block man and
you know I all I'm gonna say is I've
seen consoles have generations where
they've seen almost invincible you know
Sega had they run Nintendo for many
generations have they run again I'm not
implying that because of this happening
that this is end of Sony's run that's
not why I'm going but I am concerned
about them starting a new generation you
know I'm saying and at the end of the
day here's to do Phillip Microsoft's
coming out hard at the start for for
scarlet you know I'm saying we know
they're launching you know I'm saying
dandy with um Halo Infinite and that's
gonna be announced and stuff like that
we see them pushing the acquisitions the
game pass you know I'm saying this the
services X cloud all that stuff and
let's listen to keep it real even Sony
had to partner
with Microsoft on the azure server stuff
on the backend so I guess you know my
thing is I wonder you know saying if he
had any influence on as far as Jim Rock
you know say as far as influence
something to go on that streaming
landscape I'm very interested in his
influence your honor saying being that
now things are going in that direction
because let's be real gamers scarf that
fill in Microsoft for going in this
direction they were like this is not the
future of gaming people were like
streaming no I don't want no parts of
this and now we're seeing Sony being
aggressive and even competitive in the
space so at the end of the day every
generation is a clean slate that's how I
look at it and you have to see what's
gonna happen brand loyalty is one thing
but I know this about gamers and Babbitt
is that attest to this gamers are not
loyal if you continue to mess the people
I'm saying that continue but if people
if i console messes up we've seen it
with the Xbox one right you know and if
the other the competition has bomb games
quality games and people make decisions
listen you know and one thing I will
give Ryan this is the same statement bad
bit me which is the statement about the
incumbent platform right there's no
guarantee that didn't come it
historically didn't come your Pat form
is not generally done well so I'm having
to get out in front of that actually I
think it's a good sign for Sony you
don't say let's just see going for it
what happens man but I do feel clean
slate let's just see how this thing
plays out yes sir that's what I got we
got a fight on a super chat forum on the
Eagle sell the Eagle fighter suit chat i
play on xbox only guess what PS is dope
Nintendo's dope they just aren't my
choice fanboy ism is funny but it's
annoying play what you want hashtag fun
real estate may have a shot to fill you
guys real should this thing going last
of it
moons hearts at y'all
oonh is haunted your shadow keith has
launched i said oh my brother Bart is it
still there except out for a minute but
um yeah man so we just want to talk
about that briefly as far as our
impressions what's going on um soft do
you want to kick off the residue be
surprised man like why are you late
you're gonna be really surprised more
this is a joke every everything that
I've seen I'm gonna be honest I gotta
admit I hate destiny games and guess who
has them
Stadium clean slate
we've been around the block long enough
known to know anything could happen
but anyway wanted my boy I bought to say
let's do some last word 2.0 brother
let's get it man how you feeling
what's going on we talked about it
briefly but now we got vex invasion I'm
saying we got a guard to salvation ray
that has happened since the last word we
did on Friday you know where's your
feeling initially with shadow king I am
muted you're correct now I've actually
been really enjoying it so far I think I
think this is getting towards where
Bungie has wanted to be for years I
think this is a step in the right
direction for them to build a world that
they can evolve that can have changes
that can have evolution that goes
through the game I'm actually looking
forward to what they take what they've
done with Armour 2.0 where they can go
with weapons do I think it's perfect no
I'll say it right now I definitely
there's plenty of flaws in it as well
but I have enjoyed the time that I've
spent I think the black garden raid is
gorgeous the encounters are a lot of fun
I spend a lot of time in there yesterday
so I got my feel for it the encounters
are fun the encounters are really cool
you'll be moving a lot
oh yeah you got it you got it you're
gonna you gotta get that little
connection going on yeah alignment so
that one's pretty cool did a little bit
a little bit of the VEX offensive and
that I think changes my feeling a bit of
the moon because I was like I didn't see
any new public events and now we have
the VEX offensive so yeah I was like I
mean you didn't have public events I
mean you don't have that many new weapon
perks you don't have raid specific perks
on the weapons because I got two of them
and they're still just normal weapons
I'm starting to see little higher stat
rolls on some right here when you strike
there's 200 strikes but two new strikes
you've got three nightmare you've got
potentially six nightmare hunts actually
three that we've seen this week well we
get into strike the second strikes the
festering core I think it's on I oh so
you've got two new strikes you've got a
third one from PlayStation so but you
know some of us get to play a new strike
so we get three oh do they still have
exclusive no there are Logan's so
there's zero exclusives that's awesome
yeah so I mean that's I think this is
the nice thing for Bungie it's like I I
could go on and on about ups and downs
and things like that I kind of be
curious what you guys say and then maybe
I'll wrap my piece up at the end but I
think this is the level communication
and transparency we've seen from Luke
Smith and Bungie about what they're
going for this is the vision they're
trying to create like an actual
four-year connected story arc where we
see spoiler alert I'm not gonna talk
about the spoiler but we actually see
something in the first mission that has
been set up for years yes I like the
potential of what all this brings and as
some people other have said it's like
it's chapter one of what they actually
wanted to probably start with and I
think this is their time to truly do it
on their own do I think it is a flawless
launch no I mean the server's like they
had way too much crap to do on the first
day four hours actually wasn't too bad
stuffs gonna happen so be it but on the
other side I had before the podcast I
actually had a server limitation I don't
wait like 10 15 minutes to go down I got
plenty a quick question a quick question
half all you guys um since the
activision divorce i know obviously
activision dad
certain influences that were negative on
the game but obviously that checkbook
was big um do you see anything do
anything diminished in terms of quality
that you know you could attribute to the
big wallet from of Activision that is
missing now or do they sort of break
things down in a way that's that's kind
of more uh doable for them as opposed to
when they were with Activision
theologians uh I mean from what I've
seen it's you have it they've had
they've tried so many different models
with this over the years you have the
expansions and sd1 you had taking King
and then you had a big lull and your
eyes have ironin then you have the big
lull then they had the smaller
expansions with d2 kind of like that in
the first year then they've tried the
annual past and now they're kind of
doing a connected annual past smaller
expansions but continued changing arcs
it's it's kind of hard to compare some
of those I don't think I've seen a drop
in quality by any stretch I mean you go
through that raid you see the vex garden
offensive you see the way some of these
things have been going I think they can
continue to pace but I do think some of
the scale will probably be varied in
places where it's the you know there
could be a smaller season here because
they can't throw the other season to
another studio from Activision that
stuff could be smaller because they're
still working internally and they're
very big about not putting their debt
asunder crunch they're gonna play within
their limits so I mean there may be
smaller pieces here I think this is a
pretty decent launch especially for the
$35 price you get a lot of things for a
$35 price by comparison to many other
things so you've got a lot of content to
play and then if you add the four other
seasons on top of that for 25 or you get
them separately for 10 bucks overall I
think you've got a lot of content a fair
amount of content easily and then plenty
more for those who really enjoy it and
my bigger hope is that the story
continues to connect and build and
that's gonna add on top so generally I
don't think Bungie is going to Miss
Activision because we've got cross play
now which is huge and that's one of
those things that didn't happen because
of capital are reasons however you want
to phrase that but that's in the Vidocq
and I think generally when it comes to
like not having somebody behind them
they're free to make choices they may
fall on their face but they can choose
to adapt faster as opposed to you know
launching something a little bit later
or changing this up here they just
have more flexibility and I will red
tape yeah yeah so long what a dancer I
think I think it will be a positive
thing things may be a little smaller a
little slower but it will be of their
choice and their volition to make the
mistakes they make and ultimately make
that just the fact that it's them and
that's it I think makes the game all the
better I got a question for you guys
because I'm too lazy to use Google
I bought shadow keep on fighting to our
it won't carry over like if I wanted to
play with my friend a PC shadow keep
isn't going to carry over don't carry
over you can go to the moon you can run
around with them on the moon but if you
want to go do the raid if you want to go
to the VEX offensive like the season so
if you buy the season of undying season
will carry over that's yeah the undying
season pass will carry ok shadow keep
like in-game stuff will not you just see
more of a transparency I feel more than
ever you're not active influences there
we clearly don't see exclusive one-year
content deals anymore oh my god which I
am extremely happy about everybody Lord
addict man we've been rockin shout the
Deaf sing in a chat we was all rocket we
doing that garden of salvation but
overall man what's your feel your very
very passionate destiny player clan
member so with our shadow keep I think
as of right now because III think
destiny is a good spot now I can't speak
for the future because Bungie has a
habit of making really good decisions
and then making 5 really bad decisions
so you I have to see you know maybe
since they don't have Activision
tethered to them they can continue to
make good decisions and not make bad
decisions because I have a feeling some
of them some of the bad decisions they
didn't make was influenced by Activision
one thing I will say you know I'm I'm
guilty myself for complaining that
Bungie keeps reamping old content from
d1 and just reselling it to us in d2
there's a lot of that either
there is a lot of that in this but uh
they did it in a way that I'm okay with
my mind it I'm you know you know instead
of you know selling us oh here's a gun
that you really liked in d1 it's part of
this expansion well man I want that gun
I gotta buy the expansion you know they
didn't do that they're like look like
we're gonna tell you a good ner to focus
in a way that glitter gives you this ode
this old content and you can relive it
you don't just see it you relive it uh I
really enjoyed that this is I think this
is the only time I've ever said I was
okay with the way that they did it no
Russian he's going in he said Stockholm
Syndrome PDF he was like oh he going in
you should drop 20 views I heard I heard
satisfaction the moon the moon again
again it looked like the same one on the
left one doesn't mean there's not a lot
of difference between them same thing
just a little bit redress their content
story that we all beg for story and
content right so we get it when are we
gonna be outraged with us with them not
giving us new places and giving us same
places I mean we can sit there we could
champion the things that they should've
did right listen they made the decision
to go work with Activision they
understood they was making a deal with
the devil that's their problem
but at the same point in time we have to
pay for these sins and again we're
paying literally out of our pockets
again for content that we should have
had from the beginning so we got away
from them to get it right for us to be
right with them now like you said
Stockholm Syndrome yes we'll beat down
by these dudes all right don't get it
wrong when you when you pick up destiny
you understand the gunplay the gunplay
is phenomenal um and the way that they
switched up the the gear set and all
that other stuff I agree with everything
in line of what they're doing right now
the problem is you did this before bro
you took it away now you're giving it
back and I'm supposed to be happy that
you gave
back something of a painful before ended
regardless of me king have different
opinions on it he has every right to
fill them yes yes
purchase I'm in I'm drinking the juice
am i liking it I think you said is wrong
anyway like they do keep reselling this
old content they really good my I'm
gonna get two different zones I want to
get to different parts of the galaxy I
don't want them to say you don't know if
you think if you think about it the
first the first DLC was trials of the
Osiris thing that was literally just
bringing back mercury in a different way
the second one was pretty back Mars in a
different way you like me hmm and then
I'll see the place and then because when
I said shadow keys because you know
listen let me tell you something guys
and I really I'm not get blown smoke up
you two guys but I'm not doing it I do
really enjoy the last word for a couple
of weeks leading up to shadow keep I had
to meet you
right I like I'm one of those guys that
like to play I like to you know no I
don't you you see me I'm gonna chat and
I'm trying to play my game I'm muting
you guys I don't want to listen to you
guys when I'm listening to the story I'm
gonna be engrossed in this thing that I
love so I'm trying to experience it but
if you guys wanted to know the ins and
outs to ups and downs everything new
these guys had that information for a
minute and in telling you that this was
this and this was gonna happen so I
don't listen to the last word I'm this
is my old fraud you know your moon you
know another thing that I'm a little
upset with right now that I just thought
about cuz he brought it up mmm-hmm like
they beside I when the game came out
I'll I actually had concept on I you
know
where is the Titan love like I feel like
they can make nice raise with the water
mechanics inside like they haven't done
nothing with that plan oh what a plan
else who'd you say you know about the
place okay I got you now I just wanna
ask King before I go to bed man I want
to ask King questions I know we're
talking about the Stockholm stuff and my
question you does the announcement are
free to play effect that thought process
where the fact that they have now said
you know what you know for people who
have not played destiny we're giving you
this thing free you know and does that
soften that does that not change your
opinion as far as maybe or I'm recycling
it's time to come over here drink the
drink the kool-aid bit super set for the
first day the I thought they were trying
to juggle too many balls pause I thought
that they had too many hands all over
the planet the free to play at the
cosplay yet oh yeah you had all this
stuff that was going on at one time and
they used launching shadow keep he had
everybody trying to get on and I get
booted out a game and I come back to the
game it tells me I'm in a queue for
8,000 I really had to study great they
should have launched a new light like
two weeks early right so all right so
now you got these blueberries in here
and they're loving it and they're
figuring it out I think it was necessary
in Destiny's progression to have vanilla
destiny as a free-to-play game to get
people into the ecosystem because when
something is free-to-play then you know
there's no barrier for you unless you
want PlayStation and you need their
network in order to like but like I'm
addicted to you get it right boss but
you had to store so you're able to
purchase things to destroy and it made
this viable so they can still get they
back their money from buying things in a
store and actually now when you go to
finishers and things like canister and
different skins
I see the store as how it should have
been evolved you know and it changed to
the point where somebody told me is if I
had a gear set before I can actually get
that said that and change it to do it
right to have it
where is so again I see the evolution in
destiny I see the progression in destiny
but I also see the regression in the
fact that I'm doing what I should have
been doing from Buffy oh okay we know
why because we are apologists for
something that we love had it didn't
love we would not stand for them a game
with lore fons from RDX but a to lot of
super check can they give us better
looking armor though trash lord bad bit
man what's your quick did you get a
chance to play where you at with our
shadow key yes so again came in with the
original destiny dinklebot is that right
above me over there it I have a
love-hate relationship with destiny
I want to love this thing so bad but
like addicts right you know for the
first time and how you write them it's
like they make one decision that's
fantastic and then they'll just they'll
find the mountain to fall you know what
I know you start doing the tumbles and
and yeah so with destiny too with all
the microtransactions I hate how the
shaders still work I fell off I feel
like we do need to bring that up
you know microtransactions are crazy
yeah yeah okay have you seen the prices
on some of these things like insane want
you to purchase anything you could
purchase if you like but like I don't
like some of these they need to be in
the orangey some way like notes it's
crazy
no my thing is you can earn it or I mean
by getting a little light things or
whatever you know some of these are only
in the end in the test system and this
is what I'm gonna say if you want it you
can purchase it this is not nothing that
affects gameplay this is something that
affects your vanity so if your vanity or
your feel to have that Pokemon syndrome
like some people have they gotta have it
all you're in trouble but we're talking
about something that's still a
full-price game why they still
short for these these these ceases they
charge with you oh you know they're
gonna charge $60 for destiny three but
add it in in the before I gotta buy the
game I'm gonna buy the season and then I
gotta buy every cosmetic in the game
like you know IME cuz nobody but if you
if you want it you do and that's your
once that's a problem with you there's
too much much money exchanging going on
here I'm not saying that they need to
have like it needs to be all you do a
night call you get three or four I'm
saying some of this stuff in some way
need to be in the RG okay so baby you
feeling that you to the nice no I'm not
even saying I'm not even saying it needs
to be high I'm saved you do the
nightfall do the hardest events you have
that like thank Gjallarhorn chance it's
just like look like and not only that
what's that would that would help
promote it because you know Cognito is a
huge cosmetic person I'm not I don't
care nothing about all that stuff this
means so when I'm rocking that hard
stuff I'm rocking the hot stuff because
I got it to the nightfall carnies like
I'm doing that where is it in the shop
how you gonna do me like that I you go
juvies as the body close dude if you see
when it's something hot and it's in that
store right now you go on there option
that's much that's what I'm saying but
you know act like the kid they go
through the rating no really saying that
I say I would saying people who have
impulse buys that would see something
something that's on there doesn't even I
could have bought it but usually what
about it it's not affecting gameplay
this is cosmetic our main issue with
microtransactions or when they are
forced upon you with loot boxes and and
all this egregious stuff that affects
gaming but you gotta buy this to shorten
your time on something or get past a
level like shadow what you know all
these games have done things as gaming
this is your if you wanna keep that same
let's look at a game like overwatch
right over watch you have the obviously
they have the lootcrate system but all
of that stuff is in there like I just I
feel like if you're paying full price
and there it's not like this is a
free-to-play game it's AMA so your issue
your issue is could be if you want be
right yeah that's your issue is that
there are but at the end of the day I
bought this if you download the free to
play game do you get the whole game no
you had to buy for sake and you have to
buy that it's the questions we were
asking earlier I of like what do I get
out of what is now not like $60 for a
game is not full price anymore you know
what I mean like we have a free to play
versions of games like like fortnight
that's offering the same amount of value
for players that games like done it's
like it's not even really like I'm
condemning the game or anything like
that because I really don't care about
cosmetics I'm just saying from a
standpoint of someone say you know goes
out and buys the season pass goes out
and buy the game it's kind of ridiculous
that they want $20 for for for three
emotes yeah I want to see us see each
other yeah okay so you have for one a
studio that's completely independent
then it's this not relevant to this
conversation selling the games not
relevant okay so let exists continue II
know all I want to say is like you buy
the game you get content you have
ornaments that you can earn you have
things that you can buy everything that
is in that transaction store is optional
King said kognito said it we've all said
that it is optional if I get a gun it's
still gonna function I can get different
guns there's guns that drop from the VEX
offensive that have leaves all over the
vanilla completely different than
everything else that is all in there but
when you go into and you're like hey
this weapon has an optional look to it
and this is where you have to make that
choice they are giving the option for
people who want either support Bungie
want to put a little more behind that
game that they like or somebody who just
has that conviction of like hey this
thing looks hot I'm gonna drop five
bucks on it ten bucks on it
cool the nice thing about this at this
point is that goes straight to Bungie so
you're actually fully supporting that
developer more the
you were doing before and on top of that
you're also basically saying hey if I
want to look cool I can't but I you do
not have to it does not change anything
that nothing in ever verse changes the
game yeah to me it also like you know
with Gears of War right now they're
having a whole monetization issue I like
what rob Ferguson said is it's like
listen guys we're still working this out
we get it we're gonna change some things
so like for me the the thing that I like
about the dusty microtransactions it
trust me I eat microtransactions to
death is that they're not behind loot
boxes if I just want that one
today your rent purchase it's a direct
purchase and that into me watches say
hey I want this I got a body loot box
roll the dice big money big money no
whammy and then hope that's the
different that's promoting gambling
that's the big issue this is literally
supporting what you wash out the fun
gone brownie game before being petty
nothing hot in that store so why you
trippin with the two dollars there
there's an armor set for my Titan in
there I'm so tempted to buy it's not
even funny I haven't bought it yet but
that's me that's me it's like do I want
to spend the money cuz I want to have
these ornaments that I want to throw in
my armor and I can use them at any point
this is again the best state it's been
because I can throw that armor on any
set that I get which is the best part
it's got the most use that it's ever had
so again you may have cosmetics that are
an option and that is truly where you
have to decide it is your choice now I
know filly you set out there you miss
earning stuff in games there are some
legit sets that you can earn from the
raid set looks awesome
you've got like the really cool blue
glows and you've got different ones do I
wish there were more sets that you could
earn from like nightfall strikes and
there was exclusive armor in there yes I
wish some of those things would come
back again I never said the game was
perfect but I do think the ever verse is
probably in the best state that it's
been because they're trying to find a
way to support themselves in their game
they're giving you an option of pretty
much cosmetics for weapons skins for
armor skins for weapons
you've got sparrows ships shaders all
that stuff if you want Flair if you want
that Dominus bling
you can do it but you don't have to and
I think you know okay I would see if you
can only get this done from the ever
verse store and then it done is old P
and actually affects how you play the
game I can see that being an outcry I
could see you going crazy
but if it's just a skin that you can do
without then this balls down to vanity
fall down to you wanting your character
to look totally different from somebody
else and legit you want to flaunt how
much money you have in your bank account
to kill a team to character I have done
this on other games went out and
purchase listen Assassin's Creed origins
I ran out and I purchased stuff from the
game just to have the hot horse that was
from hell and did it and I took pictures
and I pulled it up put it online I'm
like look at me and this was like how
the hell did you do that where did that
come from
I purchased it sir because there and I
had a vanity for myself nothing that
didn't have nothing to do with anything
it was just in vain now shout out to the
Tendo breath little Wow and the amiibo
right there cuz we have seen I got a
defend st that we have seen if you
purchased these of Evo's there have been
times where whole content has been
locked behind the amiibo yes dad but uh
when I got a wolf in breath to the wild
XD gig that was assisting me through
difficult content and I believe better I
wouldn't know like I said he had
contests of myself okay that is where it
gets funny right now we're talking about
yokes I got this new suit that I want
did I change my energy
did I say instant no I guess get an
advantage if they did John that was a
sad thought I can actually keep having
me kill you better I'm gonna kill you
better than
that's where the only like gray area for
me is because for what I'm aware of
there is an exotic in the season pass
that you get for buying it which looks
dope and it is dope and it shoots like
that so you can get it for free awesome
like yes oh yeah you just get it quicker
that's it no like walking into a destiny
shadow keep I'm iffy on destiny as a
whole from what they've they've you know
I've not afeared the way the destiny
destiny or Bungie is handled DLC almost
ever
like I think Tiki King is the best
expansion yes sir ever just hands down
like you forsaken I missed I but I got
the story elements in a really good this
part like hidden in now and if you're
playing on xbox or pc a while i'm i have
to be playing on my pc son we are there
you know i love to deal with their
everyday and we're actually I'm really
proud of the clan guys we had 50 players
one day on all at one time that blew my
mind and I thank you guys when you send
me that message the other day.i bypass
jus because I try to give me an array
with you as a destiny fan I've really
like there are some things that trouble
me like king you you're correct like
dude I've been here before like this map
is like shot-for-shot destiny one well
it's been a while and so like I'm kind
of like oh yeah I remember this remember
that but it does perk me a little bit I
missed a stroke though there's a lot of
content and a lot of missions that offer
enough variety that I'm really down for
so like walking into dust the shadow
cube I just came back from Borderlands 2
I was kind of done with that universe
and whatever Randy Pitchford does that
have medieval times it's like entering
into destiny to like the variety of
these missions and all
bosses that I'm fighting so much like I
remember like scoffs yeah like crota
like awesome awesome there's some fights
that I don't recognize you that they
have a few differences too and I'm like
I really like this this is a this is
giving me a lot of challenge and at the
same exact time I played the red keep a
strike I'm gonna say dungeon because it
would work out awesome the aesthetic is
gonna feel really good so like also
playing through the story of it but I'm
like it's clicked for me I dig it now I
need to find a raid group because the
only the only platinum or the only thing
I'm missing for that platinum is I need
to complete the first raid I'll see I
completed it on PC but I need to do it
on PS worth for that plan so I like the
pretty colors and the mouse and keyboard
yes I understand all aspects yeah I
don't think none of you guys are really
wrong I think for the hardcore it is a
nostalgic trip down memory lane and a
kind of vision of where we envision
destiny to be is it perfect like I said
no there are definitely some issues we
have with it you know I'm saying you
know for me right now the jury is still
out it's early but from my opinion with
guarded salvation now I have to play
grifex offensive no but I will say it's
up there I'm not gonna if I'm gonna rank
I was gonna say this the last word on
Friday but if I'm gonna rank it right
now just emotionally off it's definitely
my thing like my top DLC it so to speak
is um Forsaken and taken King I'm sure
number one - I think mine III like taken
King more okay I I got I got forsaken
but just for the narrative they
introduced well taking didn't introduce
in anything I just felt like last wish
and it was just amazing shattered throne
was amazing the whole size of cycle but
I mean so that's that I think right now
it's kinda
in Raisa iron mold right I got a see a
little I don't know if I could put it
above yet but it's right there cuz I
think that's like probably number three
for me you know I'm saying so like a
Microsoft thing they show an initiative
but we got to see it it executed we
still have more to go you know I'm
saying obviously we still have more to
go but I think right now it's battling
for 3e where where you at with this or
what I can fibro I mean for me it's been
a really cool expansion as I said it set
up a premise for a lot of things the
spoiler that we see sets up the
potential for huge implications that
they can take the story through I think
we still have the dungeon to see we
still have these difficulties they have
the dungeon so I'm huge one I'm waiting
for
and then also we get to see their first
attempt at a story arc when we get into
the end of November with the final vex
offensive push where that culminates
where it ends and how the next season's
season of dawn actually ties into that
right so that whole arc is gonna be
something only time can tell now for me
like as filly saying it's like is there
armor I wish that was Erna balandin
everything was in the ever verse I was
still like nightfall like me the dark
blades helm like for the Titan stuff
like that I wish there were things that
you could earn that would be legit but I
think they ever versus in a really good
spot mm-hmm
do I wish more weapons had more perks on
them and they introduced more perks and
stuff in there some new mods to the
weapons yes but we keep getting new
weapons we get different feels of them
and things like that so again it again
it the game still feels good at this
point we all want more and this is I
think their first step into it so I know
I think time is gonna be one of those
things that tells but I think Bungie is
on a good track from what I can see as
for me and ranking it what you're
feeling is out of all your expansions
where is it currently sitting I mean
it's probably hovering about the same as
you forsaken is amazing taking Kings
amazing because that built on Corona and
taking Kings still might be one of my
best raids but those two are definitely
up there it's in that like battling for
third fourth spot I mean it's right cuz
those two still have the bar really high
and depending on how this art continues
its gonna hold itself I think pretty
high up there as well generally
attic you got any thoughts before you
get closer mmm
with the ranking mine has to be taking
king shadow foe and forsaken he got
fatter you got you got shy so you have
shadow keep above for six of what you
see right yeah the only issue I have
with it is the inverse that's all like
everything else I absolutely enjoy it
can I ask what you liked about shadow
keep more than forsaken because I felt
like forsaking was introducing stuff but
it was just old stuff like it sure they
introduced the same things in this but I
feel like I actually see direction like
obviously the ending showed me a
direction like forsaken it did what it
didn't mm-hmm I'm just like I want a new
enemy faction in this game so like your
whole thing I want narrative cohesion
which is what Luke Smith has been
preaching about what shadow keep the new
direction Bungie is going which is like
we were saying things and affect other
things and the game world changes that's
what you really like about shadow key
yeah and it's like you know we said
we're you know they had the intro to the
raid and you gotta go talk to a core
like you know it they're doing more that
we've been preaching for years like they
they're they're they're building on this
stuff and just doesn't drop it on you
ride right now show up at a town is
all right let's get up out of your super
long show thank everyone for rocking new
ILP poll is going up soon
with the recent eternal shake ups and
departures of PlayStation executives
from Sony how concerned are you for
PlayStation 5 for the next generation
the choices are a no concern exclusives
momentum of PlayStation 4 will continue
into next generation be very concerned
worst way to start a generation see
PlayStation 3 or C I don't care Phil
Dhabi this is on to something
you know besides see cuz obviously sees
always a troll thing well I feel like
ain't people
can be right like I really do the only
real answer see goes up on Twitter
Lord back bad big game anybody's solo
for being in a realm dealing with my
technical difficulties but we got this
show going so let's start with Lord bad
bit wicked if I'm people find you what
do you have going on sir so you can find
me over at bad big games on YouTube very
talkative Paul being fiery I know how
could be yeah we talked about all things
games who reviews top fives news all
that jazz also you can check out the
trophy room on bad big games or podcast
services around the world so if you're
into things like Playstation me and my
best friend Cal talked about PlayStation
every Thursday again oh I put it out
midnight on Wednesday so once you wake
up whatever time zone you're in you got
it there for your waiting so again
trophy room we talk about all things
PlayStation games thanks for coming guys
show tremendous content Lord Bob read
the last word vex invasion have you back
is popping in the world of uh you guys
usually find me ever it's montes eb ont
is he can find me on twitch twitter
youtube nice thing about a goofy name
it's the only one out there so if you
find the cheetah you'll likely have
tripped over my channel my twitter my
youtube whatever it is but mine's always
gonna be you know guides for you guys
anything I can to be beneficial and just
kind of covering everything in the world
of destiny and yeah there's a lot more
lately you don't recommend your channel
like five or six before work don't be
like Matt stilling I do this look if you
if you got no friends I got the perfect
channel and I thank you all for that I
appreciate the support it's been awesome
so it's been crazy so yeah you guys can
find me eben sis that's find me anywhere
you'll find me
I literally figured you were gonna cover
that me yeah okay so there's this
podcast I do with this co-host right
here it was probably gonna talk about it
we got the last word Friday mornings
right now might be switching to Friday
evenings if you get some guests on but
just stay tuned oiss to Twitter last
word pod ebon says Lord cog do you know
sitting by the campfire the ninja and
the cheetah holding out the Destiny
podcast for you guys so if you want your
dress the info we will deep dive off for
you guys opinions in everything else so
there's my waking up once again at the
end of the show it's Jeff Arthur look MJ
live with the college life was good of
it but uh Lord addict man what could
have found people find you what you have
going on sir oh you can find me a couple
place you'd find meeting this girl
cheese sandwich one you can find me a
block and sovereign off all social media
on Twitter at a Lord addict IOP but
don't tweet sovereign any because I'm
gonna say because I've walked Oh the
relationship must be repaired it was a
very it's all jokes guys meet some that
no excuse all jokes Lord sovereign extra
feisty today let's stitch sixty
sixty-nine for the two dollar to perch
at option D let's Sony burn lol
[Music]
[Music]
me on Twitter Lord sub I'll pee and PSN
xbox live being sovereign you can also
find me teaching out of had to be in
case you missed it that's the mic drop
[Applause]
[Laughter]
something right here I have the toggle
so when when it really is I had to put
on ice because it was looking really
nice anyway on shout-out to our great
wonderful guest you know is 100% family
so but bad bit my man I'm loving your
setup in the background
listen when we told me this week that he
was coming on he's like you know here
PlayStation guy I said you think he
really want to be alone this week he
told me listen you know it's all jokes I
listen I got a VR in the back of
PlayStation VR listen you know we all
played video games here so it's also in
games you know going forward we know
what's gonna happen listen guys um we
have a combat talk that's up we already
know that but we also know Kos is a
ghoshal Colossus
that love go check them out you know on
Lord kognito works on the website of
Lord of gaming the Lords of game and
that net if you're not a matter look
like major punch me in the face make
sure that your go there to get all the
new information on the stuff that we're
doing and everything like that you can
see these great statues also I was at
Comic Con this week um I'm doing the
videos now now I have probably like 30
videos that I'm trying to condense and
trying to chop and screw and put that
stuff out there so y'all can get that so
that will be up Monday so you're gonna
have content there and then the next
statue that you're gonna get but Comic
Con this year was a whole lot better
than it was in the past year for me
because I got a chance to meet on one of
my idols in the statue community and
it's very warming heartfelt warming when
you meet somebody and they live up to
your expectations mmm-hmm alright so I
want everybody that's content creators
or somebody that's a visual person
always understand that you have a fan
and always treat these people with the
utmost respect because this guy took
time out of his day talk with me we
chopped it up and it made my day
you know I smile from here the air and
it was a great experience and just
understand that you don't know if you
affect people but you do okay and
everyone you know you like you know um
who Colt says be kind and after I walked
away from Alex I realized those words
never meant more to me until that moment
be kind and you notice that that's
that's that's Coates words and it's a
real good thought and trust me you it
will go really far you don't know who
you touch at what point in time but be
nice and be kind and that's that's coach
words yeah oh yeah man you guys really
make us to give us that energy it was
tremendous to get
tremendous shot the king obviously doing
the Lord's work out there at Comic Con
and you know shout to everybody from
Lords of gaming dotnet man rapping you
guys you know as much as I can man cuz
you guys work hard for us the articles
tremendous shout the Lord old-school
style he's got some tech stuff up right
now how to get you overclock on we got
some missions Lord gene you don't I'm
saying last week from shame move we got
like I said John reading ancient defrost
adding some reviews you know so
everybody is contributing gone doors
Condor whether they're me yes
article right now he's got the apex
legend and that's also our resident
overwatch guy you know I'm saying we got
more content and more surprises for you
guys that again you already know we got
the two giveaways going up so if you
once you're deaf stranding if you want
your Pokemon shield or it all helps us
yeah man that's what I got shot a little
P Lawson Aldo they've got a believe
roundtable with the stream team that's
l-boogie old-school-style MJ the boss
those are Monday's I believe 9:00 p.m.
please do got an announcement though
before you make your announcement sir
let's go follow the wrong guy literally
was doing it while we was so at the end
I'm gonna ask him if anyone in the chat
wants smoke and Pokemon hit me up did a
game about choice at the very end tell
our super chat thank you brother great
show
sister great show thank you brother
everybody enjoy your Sunday we're out